this was recorded on january 19 2022
brian keating is a distinguished
professor of physics at the university
of california san diego and is also a
member of avilob's galileo project
assisting for the search for alien
techno signatures across the cosmos
brian also has his own podcast exploring
physics from the theoretical end to the
experimental end and he has the record
of interviewing the most nobel laureates
links to his podcast are in the
description lee cronin is the regis
chair of chemistry in the university of
glasgow and in addition to having a
velvety accent that i highly covet he's
published over 450 papers and pioneered
a new quantitative measure of complexity
called assembly theory this allows one
to look at a molecule and categorize its
complexity perhaps even with mass
spectrometry and then determine if it's
sufficiently complicated enough to have
been produced solely as a result of an
evolutionary process or by chance but
you can measure that and thus that
greatly aids the search for life outside
of earth click on the timestamp in the
description if you'd like to skip this
intro my name is kirchey mungle i'm a
torontonian filmmaker with a background
in mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of the variegated terrain of
theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as analyzing consciousness and
seeing its potential connection to
fundamental reality whatever that is
essentially this channel is dedicated to
exploring the underived nature of
reality the constitutional laws that
govern it provided those laws exist at
all and are even noble to us if you
enjoy witnessing and engaging with
others on the topics of psychology
consciousness physics etc the channel's
themes then do consider going to the
discord and the subreddit which are
linked in the description there's also a
link to the patreon that is patreon.com
kirchheim uncle if you'd like to support
this podcast as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reasons that i'm
able to have podcasts of this quality
and this depth given that i can do this
now full time thanks to both the patrons
and the sponsors support speaking of
sponsors there are two the first sponsor
is brilliant during the winter break i
decided to brush up on some of the
fundamentals of physics particularly
with regard to information theory as i'd
like to interview chiara marletto on
constructor theory which is heavily
based in information theory now
information theory is predicated on
entropy at least there's a fundamental
formula for entropy so i ended up taking
the brilliant course i challenged myself
to do one lesson per day and i took the
course's random variable distributions
and knowledge slash uncertainty what i
loved is that despite knowing the
formula for entropy which is essentially
hammered into you as an undergraduate it
seems like it comes down from the sky
arbitrarily and with brilliance for the
first time i was able to see how the
formula for entropy which you're seeing
right now is actually extremely natural
and it'd be strange to define it in any
other manner there are plenty of courses
and you can even learn group theory
which is what's being referenced when
you hear that the standard model is
predicated on u1 cross su-2 cross su-3
those are league groups continuous lead
groups visit brilliant.org
tow t-o-e to get 20 off an annual
subscription and i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons i think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you can now comprehend subjects
you previously had a difficult time
grocking the second sponsor is algo now
algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce return and
inventory write downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by amjad
hussein who's been a huge supporter of
this podcast since near its inception in
fact amjad has his own podcast on ai and
consciousness and business growth and if
you'd like to support the toe podcast
then visit the link in the description
to see amjad's podcast because
subscribing to him or at least visiting
supports the toe podcast indirectly
thank you and enjoy is that an aura ring
i got mine here
i got i joked this one you see this one
no
that's the fourth generation at stealth
oh i get it okay
do you have any words for me before we
go live by the way any of you
um just no i mean i think we can make it
kind of funny and say we're gonna brian
you say brian is in denial about his
alien abduction
[Laughter]
we'll say we'll have a nice clean toe to
toe fight
you're gonna have a theory of everything
verse theory of everything
life the universe and everything
okay so if you can see this type rocco's
modern life
rocco's modern life
this should be live now
brian you can confirm that for me
um
yes it is all right yeah
okay great thank you thank you all for
being here
to the audience and to especially to
professor keating and professor cronin
thank you
it's a pleasure to be here good to see
you lee
oh hi how's it going guys
how about you both start with your
opening statements brian you can go
first
okay well first of all i'm wishing uh
that this will be a nice clean
toe-to-toe
uh that we won't resort to any bloodshed
like our last uh confrontation with nah
lee ali has been on my channel he's a
gracious gentleman i enjoyed having him
on i refer people to uh to check out
that conversation he's given a ted talk
that was
uh surely inspirational that came out 10
years ago on my 40th birthday so you
guys can do some quick math um and
league hasn't changed a bit i've got
some some gray beard hairs as you can
see um but the reason i i suggest kurt
said you know you can have any guests
you know to have a theo locution which
is appropriate for gods like us
um in in man form and i said uh there's
no one i want to go toe-to-toe with more
than my good friend lee cronin because i
have tremendous respect
for his intellect uh for his character
for the fact that he's an
experimentalist he's a chemist not a
physicist but he that's okay some of my
best friends are chemists
and uh he does experimental work and
that's very rare kurt as you know you
have theories in your name of your
podcast we hear a lot more from the
theorists we hear from michio kaku from
our buddy eric weinstein from our
buddies you know brian green and and uh
all the like but we rarely get to hear
from experimentalists so one of the
niches i like to hopefully fill in
um is is to bring an experimentalist
standpoint to it which is first and
foremost driven by evidence
and i'm hoping that today uh if lee
agrees that we'll kind of take a tour
through what we know about the universe
what we know we don't know about the
universe specifically restricted to life
which is lee's domain much more than
mine
but i want to bring an experimental
observational astrophysics perspective
to things and even touch upon the things
that inspired me as a 12 year old kid to
get my first telescope which is the
biggest question i think there is even
though i study the origin of the
universe i still think the question of
the origin and evolution of life and the
existence of technological life would
change humanity more than anything else
except for the fact that i don't think
there's anyone else out there so i'm
going to take a contrarian point of view
not a skeptic i don't like the role of
skeptic i think that's kind of overblown
and hyperbolic um and people you don't
want to invite too many skeptics to uh
you know to a fun birthday party uh but
i want to play to play the role of uh of
somebody who would like nothing better
than for aliens for ufos for uaps to all
be
harbingers of unexplored civilizations
that are going to be hopefully
benevolent
and yet i'm coming to from a perspective
of moderation of my excitement so that i
don't get too overblown and too
optimistic and i hope that we can have a
a very spirited discussion and as i said
there's no one i'd rather have this uh
friendly blood thirsty debate with than
uh professor lee cronin who's a who's a
giant in his field and has already
accomplished a tremendous amount and yet
we differ and and hopefully by the end
we should have a rubric by which we can
apprise for the audience how much we
have learned from each other if i change
my mind if lee changes his mind so maybe
after lee's introduction we'll have kind
of a framing you know the rules of the
fight like kurt you'll be in the middle
of the ring and uh we'll go toe-to-toe
with that turn it over to my buddy lee
lee thanks brian okay were you cut yes
please go so yeah i mean this is i was
really looking forward to this because
uh brian and i both shared a rule of
scientific law that um we kind of like
data and we like experiments and we like
theory and
um i've listened to brian debate a lot
and he's very poli he's much more polite
and patient than i am so i have a lot of
respect i really have to read between
the lines and i've been involved in some
debates where people just want to catch
me out
and i and i'm no doubt brian's been in
the same place so i would say today is
probably almost going to be too
congenial but i think that's really
important because
we're both open-minded but we're
optimistic about different things now as
a chemist
i have a very
intuitive feel for the way chemistry
works on planet earth the rate at which
molecules are made and destroyed
and i'm fascinated by biology and
and actually i'm gonna i describe myself
for full um
disclosure i'm really an experimental
theorist in a way i'm not i don't think
i have the
analytical um brain to be a good
theorist but i'm really good at coming
up with
experiments to that developer theory and
i'll explain a little about that seems a
bit weird
but um
i do agree with brian i'm very skeptical
about making declarations i i don't
know if i can put a number on and i was
on my computer on about alien life or
not i wrote a paper a few years ago
which is called um
uh quantifying the origins of life on a
planetary scale
and i'll talk about the drake equation
and the fermi paradox and the chemistry
but let's let and i also want to make
this about what brian is doing very well
is saying hey
i don't i don't
know or i'm not i won't paraphrase too
much because i think he's much more
qualified to give his own point of view
given he's here so there is this kind of
gap in his intuition
and i'm going to try and fill that and
say well look i know how easy chemistry
is
i know how odd life is
and i want to make a couple of
statements the first thing is we don't
really know what life is and i don't
mean in some kind of weird kind of um
whether we are you know um projections
from an astral plane we're clearly
material i'm i'm kind of a materialist
but to kind of ch cheat on one of a copy
of what penrose said in a podcast said
i'm a materialist but i just don't know
what the matter is
right and i think that's kind of
important to understand that so that's
one point the other point is i would
appeal to at this house at the beginning
i would say there's lots of gaps
in my kind of feeling of how the
universe works so physicists typically
have i think not
not have three or four things that they
i find confusing that they conflate to
kind of think that life is odd the first
of all is the origin of the universe how
did the universe get started you'll hear
time and time again for the second law
that is that things get more disordered
over time we have more order at the
beginning so say hey where does that
order come from brian is really well
qualified to
explain that and i'm hoping that by him
explaining some of the positions i find
confusing
i'll be able to explain some of the
positions he finds confusing we might
even find ourselves agreeing which is
not a very good blood spore but let's
let's not pre-judge our agreement
because there's lots of disagreement so
physicists think that there needs to be
a um an order at the beginning of the
universe so i find that confusing
and i
the second law for me is baked into the
way i do chemistry so i get this
chemistry all these complex molecules
and they turn into life and hey presto
we get there well actually it's not like
that we don't know what it is
the other gap is that we talk about this
thing called entropy
and we also talk about what we call
causation
and kind of the emergence of information
or intention and so in my opening
statement i would just like to say there
are significant gaps in physics which
help us
we're precluded from really even
understanding why the universe is here
so i both sympathize with brian's view
but i also would like to go you know
straight back at you and say could we
could
understanding the origin of life which
i'm not so interested in i want to
understand how life forms is a phenomena
um it might even actually help us
understand what the universe is
and so my
real intuition is that
life is as easy as starting a fusion
reaction in the sky
and there are fusion reactions starting
all the time stars giving birth and
stars dying
and we need to think statistically in
that way to start to reframe the
argument now
does all life turn into intelligent life
we can debate that and talk about it but
i would say that in my opening argument
i think i see no barrier for why life
can't be common there seems to be no law
or no
gotcha in terms of resource
but i do concede we don't know what life
is but i also would kind of say you know
we don't really know how
where
the second law comes from
that we timer seems to be optional in
our universe
and we have all this jiggery pokery with
the second law and how things happen
and uh and with that i will close my
opening statement
all right let's agree on some
definitions or let's get them out of the
way so perhaps lee why don't you define
i know this is highly contentious but
why don't you define what life is and if
you can't define it then why can't you
define it and then also intelligence so
life and intelligence and then brian
add to that or tear it down
yeah yeah please tear it down so there's
more definitions of life than there are
life forms on earth thinking about it
which will give you some but i'll give
you the standard nasa definition and
i'll give you a slightly easier one
which will also blow your mind so nasa
kind of got a committee and got a lot of
really smart people together and really
you know said well okay look what are we
kind of looking for
and i'm going to get this wrong because
i i don't know if i
wrote but it's roughly saying that life
is a
self um reproducing or a sustaining
um um
evolutionary chemical system capable of
darwinian evolution i think i've almost
got it in a line and that's there's a
lot of things in there because it's
saying has to be self-sustaining there's
replication and there's darwinian
evolution there's kind of a lot of terms
and the thing for that is you have to
then get almost like the legislature out
to say you know do you qualify to be a
life form you know are you replicating
okay maybe are you metabolizing and then
you get people saying oh but fire fire
fire kind of does that why is fire not
alive and you get all trapped into
circles and people say are viruses are
they alive so i'm going to give you um
the kind of cronin
definition but actually is the probably
more like the walker definition or the
cronin walker definition and i'm i'm
collaborating with a a colleague at asu
sarah walker
who really has inspired a lot of this
and we kind of we've been developing
theory but i'll come to that later but
what i'm going to say and this is for
you the people listening
the
living systems i don't know what they
are exactly they're kind of like a bit
although they're material there's some
weird stuff but what do living systems
uniquely do that no other systems do
they create
complex objects okay
in abundance that couldn't form randomly
so be it this 3d printer tesseract which
i made on my 3d printer
um this nice um
fenix
solar watch which are the lights coming
on at the back so it's all function and
my mouse and my my body and the complex
objects that um they just couldn't
randomly form now we can define
complexity in a minute but i'm going to
give you kind of one other thing
this thing or it kind of says that this
is alive and it kind of is which will
blow your mind this is this is alive
or this is evidence of life and then
people say ah a virus is alive
and the answer is yes
viruses are produced by
um
evolutionary systems with biology and
that viruses could not
exist without the chain of events which
connects all of us
right back to that origin of life on
earth so i guess i'm saying that's the
definition for some of the aficionados
you know replication metabolism
darwinian evolution
but i would say okay that's really hard
tick box tick box why not look for
things that do complex things that we
wouldn't expect
and so that's life
to one degree then intelligence kind of
builds on that because clearly
this was not evolved in in the desert
this required human beings to invent
you know
lithography a turing machine electricity
i mean i am so proud of humanity it
might sound a bit like a bit kind of um
you know
weird but
how much creativity went into making
this silly little watch there's a solar
cell in here there are leds there's a
microprocessor there's lithographic
defined memory and there's refined
titanium i was feeling rich when i
bought when i bought this but i wanted a
light watch on my list so there's all
this cool stuff that we've done and this
clearly is evidence and i'm going to use
this term and i don't like using it but
i'm going to use it in the way that i
mean it and i'm sure brian
and you will cut me down if you think
i'm being ambiguous this is a result of
intelligent design
and what i mean a human being building
abstractions in their head were able to
leap beyond the confines of evolution
able to think about stuff and
conceptualize not having to die trying
it out and they made the watch so
all the way back definition of life
evolution chemistry
nasa my definition stuff
things that make complex things you
couldn't uh
in abundance with lots of copy numbers
that you wouldn't find
um ordinarily let's say on the moon on
the mars and
intelligent life can make objects are
even more intricate so you have three
epochs you have the random epoch just
laws of physics doing their cool stuff
the biological epoch the distribution of
objects in that in their narrows a bit
and then
and then technology and intelligence
produces a delta function the number of
transistors in here that have no
variation almost perfect is a staggering
and that's kind of long-winded but i
think i just wanted to get that out it's
quite precise and will get people
watching and listening to think really
like oh my gosh
this cup is evidence of billion years of
life because of no potter no discovery
of no clay no cup
just imagine how this this lineage this
trajectory this object this is actually
made in beijing there's some lovely
pictures on here
this is evidence of billions of years of
progress
i'll stop there
brian what are your comments on that
well yeah you know of course with the
definition as
maybe one could say flexible as
all that could you know be said to
entail of course there's there's uh it's
hard to disagree
i was preferring to think about things
you know there was a decision you you
both are not of the united states in
origin uh but there was a famous supreme
court case in the 50s i think where the
court was asked to describe what is
pornographic
and the upshot was that you know it when
you see it and i think you know we can
we can kind of uh you know debate about
things that we know for sure aren't
alive and we can debate about things
that we could all say are alive and i
think leads on to something that there
may be a deep and
maybe unassailable
interplay between the uh notion of the
conscious being that's defining life
and the order and structure uh by which
he or she ascribes that feature to be
indicative of a biological process um
normally what i hear is well life it
depends and even what is consciousness
it depends and as you know kirk there
are people that believe you know the
quarks in the cup that lee was holding
up are a lot or have consciousness in a
pan psychist format i don't know if lee
believes that or not uh but uh but i
would suspect not yes he's shaking his
head so i think uh what i think is
important is that we all sort of can
recognize the boundary cases um as not
or or yes certainly affirming to be of
life and it's kind of like you know
these debates about you know uh like
think about abortion abortion is really
controversial here in america um nobody
would say before your parents met each
other uh that you were an organism you
were a baby and nobody would say after
you know 10 months out of the womb that
you're not a living being so it's in the
it's in the superposition the
schrodinger state where it can be is it
alive is it that's where the ambiguity
comes in and the human brain as lee
knows and you know too lee
kurt
hates ambiguity we force patterns on top
of things the ambiguity bias is a
well-known psychological affair so the
question is not are the edge cases alive
um
but are the you know how do we how do we
parse and split with granularity that's
sufficient to provide the satisfaction
morally and and intellectually that
we're actually making progress so i like
that lee began or you know uh originally
he mentioned the drake equation
and we should we should actually go
through that and what that entails
because i think in that realm my field
not me specifically i don't study the
origin of life or technology et cetera
um it has has brought the most to bear
the field of astrophysics again not what
i do but the many terms in the drake
equation have been reduced in their
uncertainty has come from astrophysics
not from chemistry not from biology etc
you know from discoveries that have been
made by my colleagues not by me again so
i think what's what's important is that
we we all can first agree on the
baseline definitions on the pitch uh
which is that you know living things we
we have some vague notion of what living
things are and i think the only thing i
was a little discouraged and what lee
said originally was he doesn't want to
talk about the origin of life and i feel
like all these things are kind of
interrelated there are classic chicken
or egg type problems you know and and i
think
life chemistry etc has has a great deal
to say and i'm i'm doubly surprised
because in leigh's phenomenal ted talk
from 2011 september 9th 2011 my 40th
birthday uh he goes on and tells chris
anderson in front of a live audience
that within two years he's going to be
able to make life in his laboratory and
i don't think necessarily that you would
claim that to be a successful bet at
this point lee but i'd love to know what
what is and i'm not criticizing you
merely bringing up the fact that there
is a tendency mostly in my field to have
things like the god equation the god
particle uh the mind of god and the god
equal all these things the hype that we
have in the field of cosmology kurt is
unparalleled and i worry
that if we um if we don't avoid that in
kind of the essence of describing the
origin of life evolution of life aliens
ufos all the things we're going to talk
about today i hope we will because it's
so fascinating and has driven me since i
was a kid
nevertheless there is a tendency and a
propensity for us to believe what we
want to believe and maybe put things in
the file drawer that we find discrepant
and so
i would just say i think it is important
that we talk about the origin of life i
think that's a crucial question and i
think there's no one better on earth to
talk to than lee
i'm sure there are many better people to
talk to let's unpack it then unpack it
so yeah the ted talk i really enjoyed
doing the ted talk i was the first staff
at the ted global that year the first
stop from the start of origins um i
actually meant what i meant
and what i said in full and it sounds
like a cop-out politician you know
you know boris johnson's like i didn't
know it was a party um i i may so what i
was trying to make is two important
points and number one is that uh
that i think the origin of life is fast
and once i've worked out how to set up
the engine i'm building a uh
evolutionary engine it will take a
couple of years i stand by that
and it has been two years it's been 10
years but in the 10 years i've had to
design a programming language for
chemistry in lab and find the money and
when i went to get money from people and
i said hey guys do you want to invest in
the origin of life their eyes glaze over
and they said i said okay do you want to
invest in drug discovery oh yeah good so
what i've been doing over the years is
actually building this technology now
exists in the lab and i'm super excited
now i made a major error
many major errors i mean i completely
conceived i wasn't over hyping saying it
was j you can watch a video i was
generally like i wasn't expecting that
question i was like i don't know two
years why not that's cool let's let's go
um
um but there's there's a really
important point that um at that point i
had an intuition
um about what what to look for but i
didn't really have an experiment okay
um i didn't have a theory
i didn't have a model
and i didn't have a threshold and i was
like
can i swear on on air i was like yeah
what do you mean by threshold you didn't
have a threshold i'll come to that in a
second so i was like holy [ __ ] i have
nothing
right and then you think then i looked
at cern and how they did it so nasa
nasa couldn't find the origin of life
that oh sorry alien never life dependent
on it because they're like oh is it is
it green is it a micro tube is it false
being is it actually to be fair nasa
didn't say anything about phosphine
we'll come to that but inspired by the
machine that is was the lhc
they have the one of the best press
officers ever they had the standard
model it was a beautiful model
they had them uh they had a theory sorry
which gave rise to the standard model
they were able to simulate the standard
model and work out what energy range in
which to find the higgs so then had an
experiment build a collider go to
138.5 gev you have a better memory for
this than i do but there find a peak get
it 11 sigma
higgs job done
um you've got it so what i was going to
say is to reassure brian or to make him
decide
we're not just going for the origin of
life we're going for the phenomena that
produces life
in general think of it like uh when you
when you look up in the sky let's just
imagine that we
i don't know
it's a few hundred thousand years from
now and humans had emerged slightly
later and they look up in the sky and
all they see is the sun they don't see
any other stars
what they would do they'd be obsessing
about the origin of the sun how did it
come there's fusion where were those
hydrogen atoms those damn hydrogen atoms
how did it happen and then fusion came
but now we look up and say there's a sun
that's cool and they go over there
there's a sun look one's just died ones
have started one died so what i'm trying
to say is of course i'm studying the
origin of life but i'm not just studying
the origin of life i'm under
understanding the emergence of life in
general so i can do statistics and all i
can do in my lab is build the experiment
so now
i like okay i need to build a life
a life generator so what i need to build
a simulator of planet earth have a load
of pots load of warm ponds programming
language pumps and vowels doing all the
chemistry for you know but i don't have
a planet or 200 million years i have
some grad students
brilliant grad students 25 of them
and and four years so then i'm
multiplexing it so i've got i've got a
kind of theory which is comp
unreasonable complexity that's my theory
my model is to go and then um generate
networks of molecules that will produce
that unreasonable complexity
i then have a threshold which i can talk
about which is i kind of i published a
paper last year alien meter that kind of
works for life
and i now should go run it and i you
know i mean i've done this as time
stamped as 2022 we're getting older all
the time but i will let you know i will
tweet when the experiment is ready to
start
and i'm going to connect my complexity
to twitter and it's just going to talk
right there the chemistry that comes out
so it'll be random and what you need to
do is look at that twitter account and
when when it starts writing or when you
see patterns in the tweets you'll know a
lifeform has emerged in glasgow so yes
we are doing origin of life
um but i want to frame it more broadly
and i also think that um we i would like
to kind of just suggest that you know
the it's a it is quick so the two years
i promised that the ted talk is correct
and as brian knows from doing big
experiments political and all sorts of
things which two years are the most
important
that's right they always say you know ex
experiment or x discovery is is uh ten
years uh from now and it will always be
so uh but lee let me you know i love you
and i'm gonna keep uh harping on that
fact um so nature's under no obligation
to you know fulfill things on our grant
schedules on our on our you know
biological clocks which is a kosher form
of clock as far as i'm concerned but um
but i want to take you back to 1854
when a fellow scotsman a brilliant lad
just like yourself sir
and he was working away and he
discovered these four laws that are
eponymously named at the maxwell
equations and james clerk was working
away and he discovered that and he said
these imply and impute the laws of
electromagnetic radiation
and how can they propagate through the
seeming void uh that separates us from
the sun from all these objects that
lee's already described well it must be
the luminiferous ether the vitreous the
virtuous electromagnetic ether
and he said well how does that work and
he went through it and he had this
system of vortices gears pulleys and
ropes and so forth on a microscopic
level which is totally laughable so now
imagine leave twitter existed back then
or how about if twitter existed when
darwin wrote his letter to was it huxley
uh leo correa about the warm little pond
and he said oh it's an if and it's a
very big if
and what if you know there was a twitter
you know bot connected to darwin's warm
little pond in the 1840s 1850s or what
if miller yuri by the way yuri was
stanley uh was was
uh lee uh yuri who was harold urie
rather who was at uc san diego a mile
from my office here and he at our
chemistry department's named yuri hall
and he worked as grad student stanley
miller and they came up with this famous
miller yuri experiment which sounds an
awful lot except for the existence of a
of a computing machine next to it 1951
and uh and you could have turned it on
and and maybe connected it to a turing
machine that could then tweet uh and and
that would then you know here we are
here's the
here's the you know prototype of life
coming out and it's now it's doing
something complex organized reducing of
entropy collecting information and
providing surprise i think that's
important
and it'd be totally far off from the way
we actually believe and correct me if
i'm wrongly but i'm going to be bold
because kurt's paying us you know
handsomely to be aggressive and i'm
going to say i don't think we've made
any progress in this type of field
of miller yuri darwinian warm little
pools since
you know since those original
conjectures i think they've been shown
to be wrong not you know scientific
fraud but
there's no evidence that those chemicals
even if they could be providing
sterilized little beakers that i get at
my chemistry stock room and you get in
your chemistry stock with pipettes that
are cleaned and connected to it to an
autoclave
that even so they can reproduce actual
living organisms correct me if i'm wrong
i'm ready for the arrows
no i mean look so i i don't want to so
there's i'm stuck here as a chemist i
mean chemists have made an incredible
achievement since the time of mili yuri
right i think the the the the
the problem is
um the let me yeah so the the
experiments that mili uria did was a bit
like um
you doing
the bicep one pro er project
in 1950 and the technology wasn't there
you kind of you we kind of understood
polarization we understand about light
we didn't know anything about the
microwave background so they were they
were kind of they were kind of visionary
and that they had a hint that life
existed oh sure whereas you know the
physicists were like
there's no you know there's no big bang
there's just this steady state model and
all this stuff so they were kind of head
of the physics of that time and so what
they did they were a victim of their own
naivety of simplification
and so and so
the the progress that was made there is
they just said okay we'll just take some
very basic molecules and put them in a
flask and heat them so the middle your
experiment is literally uh a big bell
jar with a a cycle or circuit we've got
a heater and you have some water methane
hydrogen ammonia okay and these are the
elements you need for most amino acids
which will have carbon hydrogen nitrogen
oxygen some have sulfur in it but let's
leave those out here they didn't put any
sulfur in and so what they showed was
something that i am i love mathematics
i'm a much better kind of a computer
scientist and mathematician than i am a
kind of historical chemist so for me
when someone says oh here's some glycine
glycine is the simplest amino acid um
conventory it's easy to get it's like
maybe flicking three or four heads in a
row with a coin flip
okay so and and they did this with a lot
of the amino acids and so the chemists
kind of they made this and it was still
remarkable because whoa
these simple things can make amino acids
amino acids and proteins is there a link
well of course there's a link in so far
as the atoms in that jar can find their
way into amino acids but we know that
life isn't about amino acids
life is something different right and so
i don't think they've failed i think the
chemists have been asked to develop a
philosophy or develop a an ontology that
just didn't exist
and i think that so i you know and i
think the chemists are doing brilliant
things now what's happened in the 50
years well chemists have gone on and
cured disease and made interesting
molecules and we all know that i'm not
here to defend them but the analysis has
got better
but leo
aren't you guys still now with things
like the rna world which we have to
discuss i mean isn't it just redux this
this you know redux reaction now what
was the miller uri amino acid now oh no
we know the secret is rna
so i would say
um
within every field so i'm going to try
and do this as delicately as possible um
with every field you have a field that
gets stuck and they are and the origin
of life chemists are really interested
in commentary or chemistry the easiest
route to x y and z and then there and
they see a series of smoking guns and
the thing is i'm sure that brian and i
readily agree that rna is not the answer
to the origin of life but i think i have
an understanding of the underlying
theoretical framework and that's what
i'm going to push brian on in just one
moment so life has little to do with the
actual specific molecules it's a bit
like saying i can only make a motor car
that's you know i don't know let's take
a bmw i discover a bmw or then i
discover a tesla right
the only the you know the the ora does
say there's the origin of automobiles on
planet out there and it's it you know
there's no space for tesla it's just bmw
or there's no space for a bmw it's just
tesla there's only one way of doing it
or kurt's lamborghini or curtis
lamborghini
my son is into ferrari it's like that is
like ferrari all the way he's getting a
midlife crisis at age 10.
there's not one way of solving that
chemical problem and what i'm here to
reassure brian on he's like whoa
chemistry is special like it's not
the problem that chemists have
is that they um they're they are playing
around in the mess in the middle so here
let me just frame the whole discipline
i'm my my ambition in my lifetime is not
only to get to solve the origin of life
and make artificial life and find aliens
those three things are needed i think
together
um because not one of them is going to
be acceptable i think and also as the
alien discussion is going in our popular
culture right now this is something that
sarah walker has pointed out to me many
times it's really interesting that
people are excited about aliens and i
kind of disagree with brian a little bit
he says i have people just
find an alien life form they won't care
they will but it needs to be framed
properly because people want to know
they want meaning um so going back to
this origin of life and why is it wrong
well
physicists deal with
low memory systems right that's why we
call them low memory systems physicists
themselves are very high memory
individuals right they have to be good
at mathematics and modeling and so on
low memory systems that means a few
equations can broadly tell show you how
things work
not precisely then you go into chemistry
and chemistry is a bit messier there's
lots more compounds in may more common
to explosion but again chemists
alchemists whatever we can make new
materials molecules and so on then you
get to biology and that's a medium
memory
when you get to biology you have all
this contingency and evolution cambrian
explosion there are legs popping up
everywhere eyes everywhere things calm
down you get to where we we are on earth
with dinosaurs a chance of it comes
a dinosaur goes extinct mammals
run around and suddenly we have human
beings uh building iphones and youtube
and and whatever and and i think that
that
me the memory in those increases like
dramatically we can't even conceive
because physics has not
and we say it's all physics fault right
i'm have to i'm not i'm in defense of
the chemist physics that doesn't doesn't
understand entropy it's wrong the
definition of entropy is wrong um sadly
this is huge this is really huge kurt um
so lee has a very provocative unorthodox
and not necessarily accepted within phys
it doesn't mean he's wrong but i think
we should put a pin in that and
definitely want to you yeah yeah your
audience your audience needs to hear his
perspective and they hopefully will want
to hear my rebuttal too but but lee go i
don't want to interrupt you is this
related to assembly theory or is it
different yeah yeah it's about assembly
things i'm unsure how a definition can
be wrong what do you mean by the
definition of entropy is wrong that
entropy is trying to capture something
and the definition doesn't capture that
let's define entropy for a second and so
it's it's not the definition isn't wrong
it's what we need to the whole concept
is wrong
so highly it's quite it's like these are
career ending words right there would be
all the
thermodynamicists out there canceling me
but because thermodynamicists are pretty
cool guys and they're like the stats
they're not going to cancel me they
might take pity on me and teach me some
statistical mechanics so what do i mean
so if you uh what is entropy first of
all entropy very loosely is a measure of
disorder
so and and and and what we say in
general i think for a process to be
sorry i don't think that's the case do
you think that's the case brian that
it's a measure of disorder it is yeah i
know that's colloquially what it is no
no i score if you the entrance so if you
want to calculate the entropy of
something you look at the state you look
at the actual state versus the
microstate versus the number of possible
states look at the fraction of those and
and basically
at the when you look at the entropy the
value it tells you how much disorder you
have the lower the number the lower the
disorder the more order the higher the
number the higher the disorder the
higher the number of arrangements that
is the price precise definition of
entropy it goes from the molecular level
or the atomic level all the way up to
the macro level kurt i should say that
john von neumann said nobody understands
entropy so if you ever discover
something call it entropy there's like
what lee eight different shannon entropy
von neumann oh no but let's
i know how you're using it i i don't i
don't i fundamentally disagree kurt i
don't know the tricky part leon i'd like
to some clarification is that when
people use the word order we have a
certain meaning in our everyday life in
our vernacular but then when we use the
word entropy it has a specific meaning
that isn't necessarily tied to order
though it's correlated with it and you
can see this with no no no we have to
let's go back because brian will back me
up here the entropy that's used in
information theory is not correct right
it is a it is a colloquialism it is not
anchored in physical reality what is
anchored in physical reality is the
basic idea the idea of a heat engine
okay so i want to talk about the heat
engine so basically what the
thermodynamic dynamicist realized if you
want to get maximum efficiency out of
your heat engine you maximize the
temperature difference between the two
parts right and
then sorry that's a carnal efficiency
right exactly and so and brian is
agreeing because it's right it's how it
works right there now
boltzmann came along and he realized
that he could derive the existence of
molecules of atoms from this approach
it's like abenitio it was amazing right
so you could infer that these molecules
are moving around and they have these
energies associated with them and they
could be added up and they would give
you what you measure right in by
experiment now
that's that's out there what i'm saying
here is human beings create the boundary
conditions of the engine we build the
engine we do work we in we interact on
the on the boundary conditions to make
things happen and then we label the
beginning and the end and the way we
label things we label things in such a
way as an observer that we we kind of
stack the deck so we always see the
entropy change so let's pause there
because that's quite a deep thing we
have to dig down and brian will attack
it in a good way because it needs
clarification now let's go to
information and entropy
this is where things get confusing
shannon
wanted to qualify the amount of noise in
a channel if we're speaking right and he
wanted to think about the number of
possible states how surprising is it if
i get this bit do i get that bit right
and what shannon was able to do is come
up with a very nice mathematical
formalism that look very similar to
entropy
okay
on a channel but people misunderstood
and said that everything is a
communication channel but no shannon
says there has to be an encoder and a
decoder and then shannon information
is can be used
only under those circumstances no
encoder no decode the no shannon
information okay
that's what i mean so i really wanted to
take that very carefully and define
those to the best of my ability and i'm
very happy for brian to correct anything
because he's a better teacher than i am
and i think on this we broadly agree
what the definition is i think just for
for kurt and for the audience who's
incredibly erudite second only to the
into the impossible podcast audience in
terms of eridition brilliance and
alacrity of brain power no i'm just
kidding there's a podcast that brian
hosts for those who are watching called
into the impossible and i recommend you
check that out i'll leave a link in the
description
and and kurt is my uh he is my thesis
advisor and all things in youtube has
really helped me tremendously and i have
gratitude for him um so so lee is
eminently correct here i think this is
this is absolutely something that we can
we can orient uh towards and and that
only highlights again this this very
delightful and delicious you have to
understand kurt um me and lee share one
thing in common the curiosity depends on
us being mystified stymied and perhaps
even deceived by nature at certain times
our job is to not deceive ourselves or
other people to get money attention fame
etc but in these contexts when you have
ambiguity again um lee mentioned a lot
of topics in that definition which is
eminently correct in so far as we all
agree on things like temperature
we agree on on basics like uh
um the microstate what constitutes
microstates distributions and
fundamentally if we agree on time and
lee has some very very again delightful
delicious
you know possibly delusional but but
wonderful ideas about time and and its
fundamentality but let's connect let's
keep going back uh to what lee said
which i think is is brilliant and
controversial he said physicists do not
understand entropy which implies
concomitantly with that i think lee
you'll agree that we don't understand
time because time and temperature i
think you could say we might understand
but that's intimately connected to
molecules right you don't have
temperature of a single quark right
that's not substantive to talk about so
chemistry comes in and i think i would
disagree that you know chemists have a
superior understanding i think they have
insight that physicists do not
appreciate and lee is 100 correct we
don't appreciate this molecular story
and i'll just correct one thing that lee
said i don't think boltzmann you know
fundamentally you know prove the
existence of molecules i think that was
einstein later with brownie in motion
which was concomitant with boltzmann and
maxwell's earlier statistical mechanics
but let's just take this back to lee's
controversial statement which is that to
understand time and to understand
entropy we really need to understand
chemistry because they're all
fundamentally
pivoting on a very a very singular hinge
which is a chemical definition or a
practical working definition of entropy
which lee posits comes from chemistry
exclusively correctly
yeah and i think to i mean so the to
going back to boltzmann and the proof of
atoms boltzmann proved i mean you can
add it on
what einstein did that basically the
molecules
are little microstates basically and
that microwave so that's a good
correction we must get these corrections
right um so going on with entropy so
what i was saying to you kurt is that
when you you look at a process you say
oh this whole process has occurred
the entropy of the universe has
increased right it's like like some kind
of law and i keep saying to people
what is the basis for that law and this
is really tricky so we get into a
circular argument people say well of
course if we do the statistics what we
do is we count everything up
in their in their and put them in you
know how much energy you have how many
of you you know and then we then sum it
up and we look at the entropy we
calculate their number and then we look
at the change so we look at after with
before and after and we look at the
difference there now the problem is with
respect to what are we labeling
and so what i'm saying is that chem
entropy as a term
is useful if you're a god looking down
on your universe and you see the system
and you see the surroundings
if you're doing that you're good i'm not
saying that all everyone using entropy
is insane i'm saying entropy relies on
coarse graining
and coarse graining removes causation
so this is the problem because entropy
basically says everyone says there's no
causation in the universe we don't need
it there's a second law and i'm saying
no there is no second law
the second law does not need to exist if
you allow causation to exist
and then
and it removes the number of
uncertainties and my universe requires
no second law
no order at the beginning
it only requires causation and the
physical laws we already know so i
remember that it's critical let me let
me just you know because lee is a
delightful ability i wonder if he is
part part a member of the of the tribal
families because uh he talks with his
hands and and and he's just so brilliant
in his uh in his single-mindedness of
discourse but i have to put a pause so
lee is also pushing back on something
that's very controversial and he has
tremendous courage again kurt i know you
wanted to have blood on the floor of the
mat by round five i think we're probably
in round three it's gonna get there
we're gonna get bloody but one bloody
good thing that that leah said
exclusively courageously i think only on
my podcast interview with him was that
uh chemistry has quote an intelligent
design problem so what and lee takes on
these intelligent designers which i've
had on my show and and i don't mind and
leaves debated them and it's it's kosher
in my mind to talk to such people steven
c meyer james two or others um but
fundamentally he has courage lee has
courage in that he is admitting there is
a lack a lacuna in our understanding of
signs which we are comfortable with
because we are making progress towards
an understanding that hopefully would
not involve god but hopefully if it does
involve god chemist physicists around
the world could be open-minded enough to
accept and change their priors based on
that now what he said
is is fundamentally important two
minutes ago he said he doesn't require a
second law now why is the second law so
problematic for chemists who reject the
intelligent design uh hypothesis which
which which obviously lee does and and
that is that because without some low
ordered state which can get into my
field of cosmology how did inflation had
the big bang unfurl if there was no
pre-existing universe a pre-existing
collapsing state perhaps
how do you establish a low entropy state
of the universe for it to grow to
today's facility of information of
complexity of chaos of entropy by 10 to
the 100 orders of magnitude that penrose
has pointed out in the 80s already this
is a huge challenge to cosmology how do
you get to high entropy today if you
didn't start with low entropy in the
beginning people like david albert and
others have postulated something called
the past hypothesis which is basically
by fiat some entity instantiates a zero
entropy or low entropy state i don't i
think that's kind of touching on uh
almost intelligent design-like features
but lee's self-consistent if not correct
i'm saying he is self-consistent if he
can avoid the second law's validity
uniformly universally then he precludes
and excludes a need for some designer
and i just wonder lee is that driven by
some desire to eliminate a godhead or is
this fundamentally just an element of
self-consistent theory of the early
universe that leads to the chemistry
time facility that we just described
um
i mean i'm i was thinking about this
today actually because i was listening
um to something you were saying
and um no i've always really had an
intuition for
time that was different to everyone
else's and i remember my physics teacher
when i was at high school who used to
work at cern
and i was just i was saying this thing
called time and she said you understand
time is nothing it's just the ability to
watch
interactive things to happen it is if
you have to distribute energy
you have time and i was just like let's
just
i and for all these years i've just that
just for me it's just felt wrong and i
kind of ignored it and
when i came back in and i'm a very
open-minded chemist in the um
for me chemistry is a way of interacting
the universe to ask questions and when i
look around and i can see that you have
sand on a beach that is inorganic made
of silicates there might be biological
stuff in there but you've got inorganic
stuff and then you can see a blade of
grass where there's a molecular machine
in there that's assembling
taking light taking co2 and respiring
you can't help thinking
there must be some incredible force of
nature that we're misunderstanding now i
don't mean like a force of gravity but i
will introduce and this is what assembly
theory quantifies the court that that
physicists should give us a bit of
causation the physicists have taken
causation out of everything in physics
so they have to magically invoke it
which is kind of that's why we have this
free will problem now because we've got
really smart people saying i don't have
free will because i live in a
deterministic universe and then you're
just like well what are we doing this
then i might as well just run around
naked on the youtube channel because
it's already nobody acts like they have
no free will i mean that's the thing
it's like if you meet somebody who truly
believes that they have no free will and
acts upon it that person's should be
referred to i
doesn't sam harris claim but anyway i'm
digressing a bit so what i mean is that
um you have this thing that
that for me the missing force if you
like or the missing phenomena that we
are all missing by removing it by having
entropy
cheat number one
having order at the beginning of the
universe cheat number two and having
emergent time and emergent causation
sheets three and four
is that we're
we're ignoring the fact that when you've
got a universe just full of objects
let's call them just atoms right
and some energy and you start to break
symmetry
that that symmetry can select
and there's this thing called selection
and you don't need biology for selection
you don't need i don't worry there's no
pan psychism here there is just
the environment can
start to be the shepherd
for the sheep if you like and then the
sheep can become the shepherd and they
switch between the two and you get
complex behavior frozen in now this is
the
point that random events are random but
they are
absolutely monumental in the trajectory
so what i mean is you go to a billiard
table and you just start moving the
balls around
the state that you'll have a number of
bounces later will become precisely
controlled by your initial conditions
and some variations
start with different initial conditions
put different energy you'll get to a
different place now imagine
that the system is able to record that
memory of what happened before
that basically physics turns into
chemical chemistry through bond
formation and complex conventory
explosion and then that process is then
harnessed when biology is invented by
matter and you have you're able to
remember what happened to you at higher
higher dimensionality and that
is what that causation from
quarks to quacks
right we can have a quote on that
from rocks to rachmaninoff yeah
that's a much better you're much better
at this than i am brian but you you go
from this kind of non-causal system to a
causal system then act on itself so
there's two levels you get to biology
and you get causation trapped in
evolution but then when evolution
produces objects that can act on
themselves we can genetically engineer
ourselves we can play with the climate
we can play with the soil we can play
with technology you get this explosion
of further complexity and that's how it
works and i think that the universe is
literally teeming with
these engines of causation
and it doesn't need to be we could come
to a drake occasion and god you like
earth you know the fact is there's life
everywhere the sad thing is we probably
won't be able to recognize it other than
if we use assembly theory but that's
obviously my bias right and the prop the
problem i have as a theorist here is i
invented the theory and several
experiments and what my challenge is to
disprove my own theory
with
but and the problem with the discipline
i'm in is the chemist won't even engage
with it to start with and it's taken
them a very long time i have a different
i'm sorry kurt to interrupt go ahead
no i mean it's better if i don't say
anything okay it means it's going well
okay although i do have a quick question
yeah
it's for lee and for you brian what's
the definition of order that doesn't
involve entropy
because if you're saying low entropy is
order
well then that sounds like a definition
of order yet the word order was used
prior to the word entropy being invented
so this is really tough so you've asked
a really smart so i'll take a stab at it
and brian will as well you can define
information in terms of your certainty
about what's going to happen next i take
a coin right and i say i'm going to flip
my coin and i have no idea i have no
price i have no nothing to suggest that
it's a weighted coin i will assign a
prior that i'm going to give you know 50
head or sales and i'll collect data and
i'll update
when you're that so that update
constitutes some information when you're
and that is the same type of thing you
want to have a look at an order order's
a really odd thing because order is
about registry and so i would say that
order
happens when you have no constraints
let's say oh and you allow things to
cool down so let's just take a phase
transition you take some water vapor and
you know that water vapor to kind of um
precipitate and grow a
an ice crystal okay and if you allow
that to happen very slowly
the the order
will arise from the fact that molecules
in that ice crystal the water molecules
will take the correct low energy
configuration to make a nice tetrahedral
symmetry and then you'll get no defects
in there and you'll produce this perfect
object that just happens because the
laws of physics give you that so order
arises when you have no the constraints
are minimal
that's kind of a really nice definition
of order
um and it's hard because lots of people
argue and they bring in it's all
anthropologic you know
my kid's bedroom is not ordered he will
claim it is right but you know so that's
and then you then frame in these
entropic and information arguments but
you say hey what is information
information is about uncertainty what is
entropy entropy is about disorder so one
way of looking at is
causation or information for me is
almost the inverse of entropy so when i
burn something
i know how much entropy has changed so
if i burn a book
i in principle or i take a book to the
event haraju and black hole right
you're going to get all the information
back out talking radiation i won't be
able to count it but i should be able to
work out what it's roughly going to be
so it tells you what i've lost it's
never told me what i have and that's why
i'm pushing so hard on this is entropy
is almost like the inverse it tells me
that i lost stuff it can never tell me
what i had
yeah i
very much agree with that i would only
add on just another example think of a
pendulum clock a grandfather clock with
a pendulum swinging back and forth in
vacuum
you can use that to tell time
um and actually i think it's the minimal
clock of lee works a lot on minimal
systems and and systems that exhibit you
know features of the very most simple
basics and essence of the phenomena not
simple in terms of like dumb but but
simple in terms of elementary and
important
so you can have this clock swing back
and forth and you can use it to tell
time i.e this you know describe order
but if and only if you you define the
direction of the arrow of time right
because a pendulum is timed translation
symmetric if i didn't tell you where it
started i swung the plum bomb out over
here and let it go you wouldn't know uh
the absolute origin of time but uh but
you can still count time in a parametric
relative way you could say so many
cycles of the pendulum later and you
could say that's in the forward but if
the universe were you know arranged
differently the laws of physics work for
newtonian physics in the absence of heat
and so forth work uh the other way so
yes so at least right you imply some
constraint and then you can do stuff
without imposing uh this interplay
between entropy time and order but only
if you supply at least the minimum bit
of information i.e what was the initial
condition but to get back to lee's um
point i think this will go back to our
rubric that we established in the ground
rules you know when lee and i were nose
to nose at the beginning and and kurt
was like pushing us and we were like
you know at the very beginning of the
fight um
you know we we should have some
explanation of of what our priors are
and how we could change our our minds uh
so one thing that leah said just now and
said to me on my podcast and has said uh
in in many of his wonderful debates and
again i give him credit for his courage
this is so rare that you have a
publix-facing
scientist at the highest level regious
professor at the uk which is like
appointed by the queen so i think he has
to like taste test all her food make
sure she doesn't die like martin reese
he tells the queen her horoscope as the
royal astronomer lee is like that level
in in in in his profession so
let me say that again prefacing with
respect um lee is basically claimed that
life is abundant
and so to me in the universe and and
he's gone so far as to make a life
detection machine which uh after his
twitter bot you know in the warm
darwinian pool registers you know um you
know i'm setting up my twitter like jack
did you know 20 years ago
after that he's going to also you know
provide the signal coming in from the
universe autonomously generated based on
fundamental mathematical principles
connected to computational devices
turing machines
but that is predicated on this bias i
call you out i use the b word lee
you are biased that there is a life is
plentiful throughout the universe and i
have to say
you know with the drake equation which
we can write down and i give it to my
undergraduate students and and lee knows
it backwards and forwards the most
important thing in any equation lee
correct me if i'm wrong is not that you
get the answer it's how you account for
your uncertainties your statistical
uncertainties which are easy to
calculate
and your systematic uncertainties which
are very very difficult i use this
example in a talk i gave in the belly of
the beast guys i went to the seti
institute which we can talk about later
i gave a talk and said what if you apply
the drake equation to the san diego zoo
where i am
and he said how many people are in the
san diego zoo right now and i go through
the calculation i come out with a number
and it's like eight thousand
and that's great except when i do the
error bars if i account for each one of
the terms that goes into the drake
equation for the san diego zoo and feel
free to estimate some example of a fermi
type problem if you don't include the
error bars it's meaningless it's
worthless so i believe that league
should say that there's a hundred
percent you know that life is abundant
but i would i want to know his error
bars and i want to know how can he go
about reducing those error bars in other
words disproving himself rather than
confirming that life is abundant
necessarily what are the potential
pitfalls traps biases confirmation and
otherwise that this abundance detector
that you have that you have developed
and promoted
has any degree of credulity right now
that there's a hundred percent as you
said there's a hundred percent chance
i'm closer to zero percent chance of
life in the universe again no one would
like to believe it more than me
especially intelligent aliens that could
teach us the laws of physics at the 25th
century right now so i can win that
nobel prize finally but but i want to
know with you
so let me let me unpack this let me
qualify because i think i mean we're
violently agreeing so um my intuition
the way i understand how chemistry works
is i think there's life everywhere i
didn't quite say hundred percent brian
is kind of i have you on record saying a
hundred percent my i know no that's fine
it's fine i'm happy to stand by i think
it's great it's like you're
you're really putting me there and you
know going me in the corner and just
throwing the punches and i would say
that um
it it is i i i wouldn't say i'm biased
i'm optimistic
but if you were to say league how much
evidence do you have for life elsewhere
in the universe other nerf zero i have
zero evidence but i would you know i
could kind of say it brian you know
how hey brian let's let's set fire to
something right like i don't know some
carbon how much evidence do you have for
carbon being on fire in oxygen in the
universe you might
probably wouldn't probably wouldn't have
any right but he knows what happens on
earth and knows how simple it is and and
you could probably go yeah i could
probably imagine some carbon being on
fire somewhere
kelvin used to think the sun was powered
with coal right but when he did the math
he just worked out and have an energy so
totally i have no evidence there's life
elsewhere in the universe zero there's
some hints there might have been life on
mars there's some hints that there might
be some interesting stuff on venus we're
excited about going to europa and
enceladus right so i had just to be
clear for everyone listening zero i have
zero evidence does that mean that i'm
somehow life religious no no no no what
i'm saying is chemistry is so easy
so quick
and we there are so many missing gaps
what is the likelihood here is the
likelihood that life is just vanishing
it hard or is it that we don't actually
know what how how we store information
in chemical systems when an evolution
works because i i do agree
that um
there's probably life in the universe
because life is we're using life is a
very i'm using life as a very broad
capsule term for the following
i'm saying that when there is selection
there will eventually be some kind of
evolution and that evolution will
normally get give rise at some point in
time to a luca and that luca will go on
and brian is absolutely right there's
lots of fragile links in there and we
just don't know the point about the
drake equation however is this the drake
equation is not a law it's not really a
equation it's a kind of made-up thing
but i do think that brian and i should
sit down say okay
how many stars how many planets what
fraction of the planets are even you
know my motto here is let's allow any
planet where bonds are allowed covalent
bonds because covalent bonds
let's just let's allow life on or let's
allow all those to be lifeline so then
you know why i say where there's bond
there's hope
so you listen that's important because
as kurt always points out you know you
want to have these no-go theorems right
cur this is something that's a fixture
on your channel you've been paying
attention brian yeah and i'm stipulating
to you lee i'm willing to change my mind
that there is no no go theorem um you
know so in other words the probability
is greater than zero and i should never
say zero and i didn't say zero i said i
think it's closer to zero but uh but i
agree with you bonds the proclivity of
bonds and the facility of carbon to make
bonds and so forth
i would say there's lots of evidence of
chemical reaction i mean we have
examples of amino acids at high redshift
you know that we can detect and quasar
absorption features and we know
chemistry takes place in in distant
objects but but you know this main point
is well taken yeah and as i and i
continue to push back and say you know
i mean
my my my conviction is my out of my kind
of my humbleness really because
the earth isn't that special it's a rock
in the solar system we've got some
carbon we've got some oxygen yeah people
say oh it's lucky that we had a clean up
that jupiter could clean up everything
for us and all this ah i don't know we
don't know what time life emerged on
earth in 100 million years it might be
lucky for us that we have intelligent
life and i'm very happy to say to you
know i say to ufo believers all the time
the chances that an intelligent lifeform
has sent ufo to earth is like i mean
it's not zero but there are other
explanations right i mean there's other
things we can do i mean i know eric
weinstein at the moment has gone a bit
kind of ufo you know let's think about
it but i think he's doing it for not not
to be disrupt well to be disruptive not
disingenuous and to get people to take
people's temperature but coming back to
this i would say i have seen no no-go
theorems for for know why life should
exist elsewhere and given them an
internal optimist will say well look
there should be it should be everywhere
but what i'm super excited about is i
have a i'm willing to make a wager brian
is still young i'm even younger um not
that much but uh um but in the next
decade or two we're gonna go to
enceladus in europa
ann and titan and i'm willing to bet
that if they're if we do find any
evidence of life on these
um objects they will be totally
different to life on earth because i've
had a completely different history there
is no relationship whereas we might find
life on mars if we haven't put life on
mars by mistake we might find evidence
of primitive life on mars that going to
earth and seeded earth right yeah i
agree with that i mean but that pushes
things back that's just changing the day
but let me yeah yeah exactly i mean life
on earth lies on mars luckily to be
coupled that's not that's nothing if we
go to mars and we find earth like life
i'll be happy for a day
and i'll watch the nobel prizes be given
but i'm like that hasn't told me
anything new as a scientist i want to
discover something new if i went to
enceladus i found life form based on
something that isn't rna
that would be it for me that would just
be like the most amazing event in the
universe why well if i could find
different life enceladus i could start
to frame the likelihood of alien life in
our local group okay
i could think about how we could look at
making new technologies based on living
systems on earth and really even more
important in fact i almost have the same
passion that brian has for understand
the origin of the universe
um for this is that if we can make life
on earth and understand the origin of
life we might be able to start to accept
that life on earth that we have right
now in our ecosystem is very precious
and how is a thing and we need to think
about framing
this
living artifact this little cultural
you know jewel that we need to keep to
be as persistent for as long as possible
and to create maximum flourishing for
our little moral kind of
work part in the universe so i think
almost way if you know there are two
films i watched i know i'm talking a lot
but there's two films that came out the
same year one called adastra which was
the most depressing the brian keating
moving you know
you're just as good looking as brad pitt
you know
so and then you know and there is
another film called cosmos which was a
low-budget uk movie which i like and you
should watch them because one basically
both about should we find life and one
finds life very optimistic comes to
earth and says we're here and the other
one is like miserable there's no life
anywhere and for me
i i think the difference between us is
i'm an optimist because i understand my
chemistry and i'm a chemist you're an
optimist in your field you understand
that and i'm trying to i'm trying to
borrow a bit of your
intuition and i'm trying to lend you a
bit of mind and see if we can change
each other's mind from that point of
view but you're absolutely right
i have no evidence but i have no reason
why it can't happen there is nothing
magic about life on earth
yeah well i wonder if we could have a
no-go theorem if you uh if you would
agree and then you know perhaps that
would make our our generous host
generous good looking and uh and uh just
with a delightful aroma although i've
never met him in person kurt's one of my
best friends that i've never met in
person i hope to rectify that in the
very near future you too lee um but you
brought up eric you brought up and so i
find that there is sort of a uh a wish
fulfillment aspect in in in many of
these things including in this huge and
deservedly so excitement over jwst i
mean i basically heard people portraying
one of the science cases for jwst
tantamount to well we're gonna see like
cities on exoplanet you know like no
you're not you're gonna see like
spectral lines and and often eric has
talked about data and collecting data um
and and it's our data the hubble space
telescopes are like
well it's data but like take the hubble
deep field i love mentioning this topic
so the hubble deep field is data but
actually we don't use it uh the data the
image for anything it's a screen saver i
call it the cosmic screen saver cosmic
wallpaper and that's all the image
itself is the data is within it so if
there's a ufo floating around in there
that is not the same as what astronomers
call the type of evidence that we
associate with data stuff that we can be
quantitative and analyze spectral time
domain uh multi-waterfall display you
know we can do a ton of stuff with
actual with the photon information not
just the image information the picture
information
um now mentioning this there there
there are you know concerns about what
the implication would be and so i'm
curious to to know why if life is so
abundant and then you sprinkle in some
darwinian evolution why isn't you know a
technological life abundant and why
isn't it more plausible than not it
seems like you're saying you're you're
kind of a
a life maximalist but a ufo minimalist
so so tell me what how can you rectify
those two things because it would seem
to me unless there's a no-go theorem
against it that maybe there is more hope
i get around that by saying i don't
think life exists elsewhere besides the
earth and if it does it's from the earth
via panspermic processes but but tell me
what what could potentially uh forbid
life from evolving technologically
yeah yeah so so i'm going to say a
couple of things so i think kurt if you
want to go to assembly through we'll do
that in a minute so i think it's quite
important story but let me answer
brian's question i actually so i think
you know there's a scooby-doo you know
the way the villain says you pissed
pesky kids i'm gonna say the reason why
we can't see technological life is you
pesky physicists because the universe is
really big and things are accelerating
away and it's you know and sadly
um you know i'd love to break the i'd
love to understand more about the the
way the universe is and the speed of
light and get around but the fact is
there seems to be little indication that
we can have wormholes and and break the
speed of light and and you know
designing
as a quick clarification i'm sorry to
interject lee then when you say that
life is abundant in the universe are you
not referring to the observable universe
sure i think it's abundant in the
observable universe and we'll learn how
to find it and i think actually
frustratingly we probably will find
techno signatures
you know hints of them and not just
hints hints that brian and i will look
at the data we'll look at the
uncertainty the error bars your point is
taken i haven't forgotten it's a very
good point brian and we will then go
well the balance is fact here is like we
will be it is possible remotely to get
data
uh um squeeze down those areas and know
for sure there's alien technological
life elsewhere in the universe we could
do it okay and don't let nasa and other
people say it's not we can do it we can
detect the higgs boson if we can look at
the cosmic microwave background we will
be our fine technological um signatures
but we but we need a better theory which
i'm trying to introduce it might not be
the right one but i've got a feeling
it's going that direction but to answer
the question where all the technology is
there's a number of answers to that but
i want to say something quite profound
if time really is a thing and let's say
time is a commodity
and at the beginning of our local
universe where the laws are now i'm
going to define time and this is going
to be like
i mean i'm not a very good singer but
this is going to be like brian hearing a
really bad singer
and he's like breaking physics but here
i'll try
at the origin of the universe there was
some kind of singularity which basically
we seem to be we were kind of one
quantumly connected one particle let's
say and through that causal
aperture
the
the the the size of the electron the
what you know the the the charge to mass
ratio of the electron the gravitational
for all the forces would produce or all
that was produced there right in that
single point because people say the laws
and all the constants the constants are
just contingencies right and so so we
have that
and then from that that process that
point in time where the universe
expanded
and i think
again brian has the history of the
universe down like i think if i remember
i'm studying you that all the hydrogen
in the universe was made in the first 20
minutes or something which is just a
mind-blowing uh kind of fact and it's
true than the big bang theory tv show
exactly that's great so now you've got
this stuff right
in time
now the reason is a clock is ticking now
at that time you don't have enough
states in the universe
to actually produce life it's kind of
cool
basically you actually they're the fermi
paradox and i'm saying i have to qualify
this because i'm stealing this idea i
agree with it from sarah walker so i you
know i'm not very good well i should be
clear i should steal more ideas but but
she's convinced me and i and i also
think it's true it's a natural
consequence of assembly theory the fermi
paradox is not about the fact that we
that we don't see the aliens just
the we're looking back in time and at
that time the universe didn't have the
ability to produce technology so it's
like a fermi filter now think for a
second it's like oh [ __ ]
we looking back in time the universe
didn't have the ability to produce
technology at that time
we have to look in a different way
actually i'll push back again uh just to
say that there was an epoch in the
universe where you didn't need a hard
rocky planet to sustain uh room
temperature liquid water and that was a
time about you know eight billion years
ago when the universe curt was at the
temperature above zero degrees celsius
which is uh you know about about 50
degrees warmer than it is in toronto or
glasgow i'm just trying to make you guys
jealous you'll visit me here in san
diego in january sometime
so the universe could have liquid water
for millions billions of years until it
becomes frozen water um and so actually
no there there's a reverse filter there
there's sort of a city no no no no
that's that i have to push back that's
quite nice but i'm saying
something very
profound in terms of the the number of
states available i don't care how much
water's available who cares what i care
about is a combinatorial state space
remember i'm not a chemist here i'm a
mathematician within the states so
you're right with kurt but kurt the
amount i'm going to have sarah on my
show next week but but i'll ask her
about this but the the i mean is it
galaxy is one galaxy sufficient uh space
state space to create technological life
obviously this is what we're this is
what i think i think the answer is no
right and i what we just let's just keep
going with this arguing there's let's
just make a conjecture i don't know
right but isn't it interesting you've
got a smaller volume of the universe
time is the thing so you're not going
back and forth so you have to
um there's this causal chain of events i
don't know how delicate it plays into
your argument really nicely what
sequence of events have to happen in the
first 20 minutes the next 200 million
years the next two billion years to
prepare the universe to be able to
metabolize elements fusion right
produce objects that can then have
enough structure enough surface area for
selection to occur
over a period of time so you might not
you might need stability of a few
hundred million years with a certain
gravitational force but let's not add
that on i'm just saying hey wouldn't it
be cool if the fermi paradox is actually
just evidence the universe had not yet
had enough causal history to produce
life
we popped up as soon as it could so we
should go ah okay let's now i'll say
let's just make this very simple for
ourselves and say life in the universe
kind of started to emerge when life
let's say there's nothing special about
earth
happened quickly so life was possible in
the universe about four billion years
ago and so what we now do is we reframe
our observations and we look around i'm
just making this up so no idea i had
today thanks to sarah's idea and brian's
question and yours did you come up with
the metabolized elements because that's
a cool line i'm going to steal that yeah
yeah i just made it up i wouldn't steal
it from sarah i would steal it from you
no no no i you could steal that from me
i just made it up just now um and so
you've kind of got this idea that
basically
um you're creating this infrastructure
for causation
that that allows you to go a bit further
and and so what happens i don't know i
mean if only we had an astronomer who
understood how to look back here like if
you read through the lines of right
we're going to now restrict ourselves
looking for a 4 billion
year old light cone and we look at the
exoplanets other objects how does that
reframe
the search for life or intelligence so i
mean there's lots of ideas there so the
conjecture is
there is a filter that is just the
universe wasn't capable of producing
life until a particular time now it is
then technology and then how does that
go on and that plays into redoing our
error bars in the in the in the in the
fermi paradox and in the drake equation
and also i hide my only shield brian is
i don't see anything magic on earth
so it's probably possible elsewhere
because okay so that's a great point let
me interject because you're
it's difficult to interject without
interrupting i'm sorry lee no no it's
all good your podcast uh you you beat us
in come on yeah okay great you use many
ants and so i'm not sure if the sentence
is complete or if it's run on and i
don't want to seem rude okay so brian
you just made a great point what is an
example of some other phenomenon that
happens on earth that doesn't occur
elsewhere in the universe so water waves
maybe one well there's maybe water waves
and mountains atmosphere okay so
given that it sounds like there's
nothing special about earth's life so
why are you isolating earth's life
as saying well that's unique
on example
if these plot you know it's like they
want to have their you know primordial
soup and eat it too you know they want
to say it's ubiquitous these processes
are generic
and yet not seeing it you know it's more
than just a fermi paradox and i will
push back on sarah gently with respect
uh because i love her work uh
but but the fact is you know though
those are almost borderline you know
kind of ideas that i hear from
intelligent designers too you know which
is that the laws of physics the state
space of the laws of physics the
constants of nature the mass of the
electron the uh fine structure constant
all the things you talked about are
implied um those you know are can be con
conflated with you know some kind of low
entropy state instantiated by a designer
i don't want to talk about that
except to say that i don't think that
that pushes the pro that filter is very
fine cor fine grain and i will talk to
her about it but i do want to say that
again generically speaking these
processes are ubiquitous so therefore
the non-observation like that should go
into the fermi paradox not that the
universe is large
uh that these processes are uh you know
we just detected uh you know we've
detected uh helioseismological effects
on other stars we've detected uh the
existence of you know what we think are
continental you know patterns so
tectonic you know potential potentiality
for tectonic activity which we do
believe some believe are but all this
kind of pushes things back like one of
my big um gripes against the seti
institute which i know and love and i've
had jill tarter and seth sostak and i've
donated to them um and and i've spoken
there but you know i started to get a
little bit suspicious when a couple
years ago they started shifting away
from the existence of live techno
signatures to extremophiles here on
earth i don't think that necessarily
answers or gets to the heart of the
question certainly not of
extraterrestrial intelligence to know
some smokey uh that deep smoker has uh
you know has bacteria or cyanogenic
bacteria or or prokaryotic type whatever
that's interesting but it's not aligned
with eti that's what i care about i mean
yeah let's cut the bs what we really
care about is making contact as eric
says you know if you could short circuit
and get to the laws of the 25th century
and get to the other side maybe we would
pass the great filter you know as it's
been called and protect ourselves and i
i happen to think that might be wishful
thinking uh but i commend eric for
working on y'all theory to perhaps
unlock some of these uh some of these
portals as he calls it um but but
nevertheless i i think again
is there you know is there a rubric that
you and i could agree on or or disagree
on and i think the audience would like
to know are are there um in other words
if you hear you know there's been an a
credible account louis elizondo past
guests on kurt show
you know has claimed you know really
very very
high credence levels in the existence of
extraterrestrials capable of
technologically navigating across our
galaxy correct me if i'm misstating or
overstating and the basic point as a
physicist cares about um and that is um
you know non god bless you lee non god
bless you or whatever
darwin bless you darwin bless you when
you sneeze i have to say that uh but but
he's making this so can we by laws of
chemistry physics assembly whatever can
we say no we actually shouldn't have the
cr you know credulity that lee that uh
that luis has uh and instead we should
he should update his priors based on
these following chemical physical
mathematical laws is there a way that we
can do that for them i think so i think
there's a way to do this let me just
answer a little bit and then i'll
explain assembly theory so yeah i think
what i think is likely to happen
if
i mean i don't know i mean like i have
no
i'm a curious i would i think it's
likely that we if life exists in the
solar system
some chemical lice life
um i'm i'm optimistic that we'll go and
find some evidence with some
you know sending dragonfly to titan the
mass spectrometer on it we're going to
hopefully go to europa and so on
we're going to hopefully do origin of
life on earth and when i succeed but
don't get the nobel prize i can write my
other book you know i can get brian to
do it forward in it and all that because
we chemisted it and what we're likely to
do i think is we should be looking for
technology technological techno
signatures
you know i mean i think that the
exoplanet we're going to detect an
exoplanet of oxygen on it and so we
found life and that's just going to be
baloney so that's that i agree with
brian so let me just tell you briefly
what assembly theory is because assembly
theory is actually a kind of a cool way
of actually
doing entropy without labeling and it's
just about
as a chemist i realized years ago
that there are molecules on earth that
are just weird right weird molecules
like really complex and so let's just
take a molecule that i that is used a
lot called taxol taxol
is made by the pacific yew tree it's a
metabolism it's a it's a it's a
secondary metabolite which means it's
made by protein interaction proteins in
the cell and that molecule is really
special because it's very good at um
killing vascular polarization of cancer
tumors so people get that and they they
they use it as an anti-cancer drug now
to make this molecule it's like got 62
carbon atoms you know a load of oxygen
atoms nitrogen and so on in this pattern
and this molecule has a molecular weight
of about um 852.66
something like this so i'm going to go
and check it now
it's like okay like i'll google it
whilst i'm saying but it's a big
molecular weight and it's a fingerprint
and the way that molecule works is the
way the combinatorial chemistry works
that molecule
is
beautiful it's like a rembrandt right
it's in its features
but chemists can make loads of it so you
can make literally
10 to the 23
6.022 times 10 to the 23 and that's one
mole so you have one mole of taxol so
that's
10 to the 23 identical copies and that's
made in biology on earth human beings
can make it in the lab but
if brian and i did the math together and
we said right we'll look at that
molecule we'll work out what is the
probability that that molecule
could form randomly in a plasma in the
universe
it's basically one in a like
countless in 10 100 right maybe more
that's just for one molecule so if you
find a detectable amount you're like oh
oh my god this is like the biggest
coincidence ever so that's where
assembly theory was born
and i realized that there's lots of
molecules on earth that pass the great
filter they are made by biology and i
realize they can make a detection system
that detects molecules that are above
that threshold of complexity and that
when you do random miliuri and random
stuff
get meteorites and look at the organic
chemistry they are way below that filter
they have an assembly number and what
assembly theory does is it says like
take your molecule put it on a graph
what is the shortest route you can get
from your atoms to that target the
shortest possible route how many steps
right so it's a bit like you take the
word abracadabra if you were to make if
you've got a b
uh um you know c r a how many steps
would you need to make the word
abracadabra well you can do it in in a
much number the number of letters in the
in the word because you can reuse some
parts and so my conjecture is assembly
theory says it finds where there's
memory of contingency in a chain so it
looks for lossless compressibility
that's kind of cool right it's a bit
like a information theory compression
shannon
but it's just like that what is your
shortest route to get there because
like brian
i'm as an experimentalist the data is
more important than my feelings that's
right and so you know it's like
so i'm like ben shapiro you just sounded
like ben shapiro for a second
yeah i love ben shapiro
and so
it's really important that we understand
that because
it work it's pervasive right where
people just think that and chemists
think that complex molecules this is
where the chemists
they're getting they're beginning to
change their view
and what i'm trying to say is that the
the chemists don't because they take it
for granted that there's complex
chemistry everyone saying hey guys it's
not just rna that's important atp is
important you know that's my that's my
joke lee i say you know and in in
economics you know past performance is
no guarantee of future results it's like
we have past performance evidence here
on earth but
that's no guarantee so assembly theory
what it does it allows you given a
complex molecule you can work out the
likelihood it formed by chance
and and that i think is fairly
irrefutable although publishing that
paper last year took me six goes right i
sent it to them why do you think that is
well because they are well it took me i
sense of nature i almost got in right
senate nature i got three reports back
two said wow one said
can't be right
so i wrote back and and so they later
what do we do and i said well we can ask
the referee why it can't be right so he
said i'll do that then and the referee
said the referee why can't it be right
and the referee said in the second round
because it's impossible
we're like okay this is like i kid you
not right this is a conversation we had
with the editor i said but here's the
data are you saying we fabricated the
data
and the referee just said it's
impossible
and we we went in this loop and what
actually happened is one of the referees
fabricated
a data from a paper to assert that we
couldn't be right that's how desperate
they were i got the evidence right come
back
they said in this paper it says that
complexity is important is already
present in outer space blah blah blah
blah
and and the editor read it went off
reject again and when i pointed to the
editor
that the referee took the word complex
mixtures have been found in space and
changed it to complex molecules because
they were so believing the complex
molecules are a free lunch
um
i then went to the fifth round to review
and the editor by this point was like
just like
go away we're not publishing i said no
we're gonna i believe in the rule of
peer review i'm answering all your
points
this is important it's important we
change people's views of complexity
because brian is on a really good side
we're saying hey i want the data i know
that nothing is for free and the chemist
in the middle saying everything is for
free complexity happens and i'm in the
middle saying no i can count it and
quantify and here it is what actually
happened it was rejected
right because of for i won't go into i
don't want to complain i'm a very lucky
scientist i love doing the science i
just feel bad for the research group but
i got it published i published it in
nature communications and that paper was
downloaded 27 000 times in five months
um because we presented the theory the
mass spec and all the evidence we had a
little meteorites we even got scottish
whiskey and we proved that scottish
whiskey is evidence of life because
there's complexity in the peak right we
show it works so we know we can
fingerprint life on earth and molecules
um and so it's but we realized something
more that assembly theory is about just
something about molecules it's about
every time you have a step on your path
and you make a decision let's say you go
down the street you say i'm going to go
left today you go left and say right i'm
going to go left again then i'm going to
go right and go left and right and you
find yourself in a very particular spot
that contingency is pretty on your
history right there's a lot of
mathematics on that
and we're finding that this is the
the assembly theory that we generate and
i haven't spoken to brian about it
because sarah and i just finishing the
paper and oh my god it works and what i
mean by that i mean i can take a
kilogram of sand and calculate the
assembly of that kilogram of sand and i
can calculate take a kilogram of e coli
and calculate the assembly assembly is a
number like entropy
and entropy tells you the causal power
of the object and of course the causal
power of a kilogram of aquila of e coli
is vastly higher than the kilogram of
sand because the sound can do nothing so
what about the uh assembly of rule 38
wolfram's you know rule well and
you'll hear about this in a few weeks
maybe but the problem with that is that
is again a labeled system so rule 38
doesn't exist outside of a von neumann
machine and graph paper an observer
putting in the rules in so yeah so
there's so the problem is and physicists
get stuck with things that give
complexity that aren't really complexity
it's just games with numbers
and and i think that i've got a little
bit of work to do with that and i think
the wolfram's ideas here are pretty cool
i think they're not they're not the
problem is with wolfram he traps himself
in a line of thought and doesn't talk to
anyone and think he's the lost genius
bit like eric actually and no one will
talk to him we'll talk to him in fact
he's got a lot of good ideas that might
actually be right but it's [ __ ] up
i've had not only have i talked to him
and i've talked to eric i've talked to
him and eric at the same time i'm like
oh cool i'd love to take part in that
conversation if i maybe could bang their
heads together
assembly theory tells you about
causation it's now measurable
and that's why i'm excited because we're
going to start to roll this out
in inanimate objects and it will help
physics i think newton screwed physics
because screw
n newton and there's a hell of a thing
to say i'm british right i love newton
you know there's a lot of coins and on
our notes and everything but leibniz
understood assembly theory and i've been
reading philosophy for the last few
weeks if you read the monodology from
leibniz you'll see that he understood
assembly theory and that objects have
souls
this cup has a soul and you're like okay
there's legal on or pants i can say no
no the soul is not in the cup but it's
in the causal structure of the person
that made it who made it who made it who
made it this cup is a fantastically
improbable object that cannot have
existed at a long line
of cup makers that's where the soul of
the cup is okay let's let brian respond
to what you've said
well you know i think i mean it's
unassailable to say that you know
complexity begets complexity and again
that lee will take on intelligent
designers with one fist but he'll also
you know take on chemists uh with the
other and say look we we have to address
you know as as uh
as uh you know roger penrose calls the
mastodon in the room which is you know
this surprising you know uh feature
about the universe that we can
comprehend it we tend to impose you know
consciousness upon it and our
definitions our contingent upon our
causal history and how we were assembled
you know and i think the ultimate theory
of everything when it comes to uh what
lee's working on will have to involve
the observer which will undoubtedly then
finally force him to get into
fundamentals of of quantum mechanics
which i don't think he can call
chemistry i'm okay with you calling you
know entropy and thermodynamics
chemistry but i think you know the uh
elementary foundations of quantum
mechanics that's a stretch i've always
wanted to be a physicist that's okay
okay yeah well me too but you know i i
lapsed and became an astrophysicist
but i think um
you know when we talk about how uh you
know this this could be used to to kind
of um
as i say be quantitative how we can get
something out of it deliver some value
to the audience uh certainly these are
and the last the more flexible we are i
think the more can be understood but
maybe maybe to even narrow down and come
back to the original definition of
things i think to have a taxonomy you
know what what is it that the the name
is not the thing uh there's there's some
principle like that right um and so so
yes describing things that are complex
and are have originators in a mind that
on the one hand is beautiful it's
elegant it's it's simple and again in a
in a praiseworthy fashion not in a
childless fashion on the other hand i do
think we have to then confront the
ultimate you know question of you know
is there does there have to be some mind
at work behind the cup behind the 747
behind the uh the the dna code and i i
think we know we've agreed not to really
get into this this notion but i think it
at some level we just get to this uh a a
eventual chicken or egg and this monta
bailey you know retreat and and i guess
you know
i think i think the ultimate you know uh
the ultimate benefit of this approach is
is that it it gives a plausible scenario
for life to arise from inanimate objects
that's that's an ultimate it's a way to
quantify when something is animate let's
just say or was created by something
adamant um
and i think you know to look at how
we can do better and and maybe go
further into which i think is really
important uh you know is life abundant
and technological i think kurt's
audience appreciates that and i think
you know we haven't spoken so much about
that maybe we can talk about that um you
know how and what could we glean from
the search as a search you know and
where are we going quovatus you know
where are we going with with the search
is it important is a good use of of
chemist's time of physicist time uh et
cetera to look at these uh reported
unexplained phenomena um can that tell
us something is this something that
interests you and and me and and maybe
you know kurt can can lead us in that
path and and kind of yeah really i mean
we're at a very interesting you know
point in time and a lot of it has to do
with people that kurtz had on the show
and that i've tried to have on my
podcast as well um and i think that you
know kind of the abiogenesis
argument is is you know you've
eloquently described it um i think you
know if we look maybe as curt as an
impartial observer maybe we could say
like where are you kurt in this
discussion because i think you're a
proxy for your earlier audience how do
we how how are you feeling about the
prospects of the ultimate question
life from non-life and then we can talk
about universe from non-universe we can
talk about consciousness from inanimate
matter and we can talk about
technological matter from conscious
matter but um where are you sitting
right now kurt
if we use
lee's definition of life which is
what begets some high assembly number
then it sounds like
it's almost like pan psychos and
pan-lifeism because it's a circular
definition of life where okay well what
would produce that well then we'd get
down to the atoms which produce and so
on and so on so it sounds like life is
abundant if we use the definition that
life is what produces life
let me qualify one second no so what i'm
saying is you have
random events
that basically um
increasing causal power and there's a
phase transition to life right life
doesn't just appear magically right
we've already there is but there's a
causation in the universe right the
universe does do some stuff before life
there's a phase transition because and
then evolution can do stuff
like which is just you can and what it
what can and we there is a meaning to
this which we can come to it's not pan
psychism i totally refute well no let's
be friendly to the pan psychics because
there are interesting things there but i
think there's a mischaracterization
the pan psychists want something there
but i would argue they want causation
and they want and they're missing out on
causation so there's causations there
and then there's biology and then
there's technology so i'm i'm i don't
think it's circular but i think you're
really right push on it because i think
your your listeners your viewers will be
like well come on it what do i mean i
mean rocks can
through their random interactions can
have memories and those memories just
randomly will be
um trapped in the causal chain which
will allow certain other processes to
occur it's not magic it's contingent
tell me if i'm understanding it
correctly it sounds like in your model
life is not binary it's not alive or
dead it's actually a continuous spectrum
and if that's the case then what i'm
saying that there is no zero to life
there's no zero i think life is a kind
of island right this is why we have so
difficult pinning it down the physics
it's like is this is my cup alive no was
my cup produced by life yes am i alive
yes i think so um you know
so this kind of this is a movable feast
in a way in the same way consciousness
is kind of we have more so agency we
have maximum agency in our bodies right
now but newton is still exerting agency
over all of us
because of what he did
that life form and it's kind of cool so
yes you're absolutely right i think life
is kind of a continuum and there's a
phase transition to you have there is
really a lot of causal power and you get
something special with that that faith
transition is an intuition at this point
is it formalized
we're formalizing it and doing
experiments and i think that exactly
there's a nobel prize there the nobel
prize there's another product i mean
they're like everywhere i mean let me
talk about your fools if that's all
right let me just ask one more question
sure just
if you have an assembly theory and
computation and all these wonderful
things um could you have a bs detector i
mean could you say you know now now you
feed in some um
some left-handed dna i think that's the
uh non-uh stereoisomer that occur
doesn't occur in life that we know about
so
look what i found you know would this
then tell you that there there's this
there's some trickery and some jiggery
pokery as you say i mean
could it tell that this is not and is
that instantiated by you lee did you put
in if you see a left-handed dna helix
you know the guy is a fraud you know
tell me how does that how would that be
it's a sneaky way of asking about the
lab league theory
[Laughter]
well
actually um it's not cheeky it's
actually entirely appropriate so uh but
maybe we don't need to go down there
yeah please i want to stay monetized
okay good um
i use assembly theory a very crude
version to show
some plagiarism so because because
plagiarism is the ultimate um uh
kind of you know
commendation right and when melina trump
gave her
presentation to the cup republican
convention
she used a speech which was the same as
michelle obama's speech
and it was like they look the same and i
was like oh wow let's take all the
subjects of the sentences and i broke
them down and with assembly theory be
like you know um on number one i talked
about my you know my my mom my my
country and number two i talked about my
childhood number three i talked about my
dog number three you know you went
through and went wow when i by the time
i got to 14 and a match i knew that that
was plagiarism right because the the
chances of that
not being was like you know 14 factorial
or something right so it was kind of
cool it's like yeah so so you can use it
as a bs detector
and and yes you can use it to look for
genetic material and look for motifs
repeating
and and then you can see what
engineering has been done and what
evolution has done and it should be
possible to get get that because entropy
course grains it all out assembly
reassembles it okay so now the next
question will dovetail into what kurt
was just about to ask which is could
there be an analog of assembly theory to
apply to unidentified aerial phenomena
kurt is that is that okay to ask
sure i'd also like to explain re-explain
if you don't mind myself to the audience
and then you can correct my explanation
of assembly theory because it's
extremely important okay okay so
lee cronin has a number it's almost like
kolmogorov complexity so those of you
who know what that is there are
different forms of
of putting a number to a piece of
information to see how complex it is
and what you have in lee's theory is you
have elements that you consider to be
atomic so you can consider those to be
axioms and then you have certain rules
of inference now those rules of
inference are like the laws of physics
though this can also be applied to
mathematics and that's why i think it's
extremely interesting because you can
quantify how difficult a formula is to
prove anyway so you have you have atoms
and then you have rules of inference and
then you wonder what is the minimum
amount of steps to get from the axioms
to the stated formula so for example the
word candy if we consider the letters of
the alphabet to be atomic then the word
candies complexity is five so you think
well that makes sense it's five letters
yeah because step one you pull c out
step two you pull an a out but the word
pom poms which is seven letters is
complexity of five because you p okay
you pull a p out that's step one pull an
o out pull an m out then you need to put
another p but great we have the word
palm already created so that's that step
is taken care of by simply duplicating
the palm so then we have another step
for the s so then that's five in total
now is that a correct summation okay
yeah yeah you'll hive
great you're great okay and and the the
reason this is extremely fascinating is
because you can use certain instruments
like mass spectrometry potentially to
assess the complexity of far away
molecules and then you can see well look
h2o maybe has a complexity of four i
don't know maybe five whatever doesn't
matter two hydrogen one oxygen but a
simple protein may have 400 steps a
simple protein and thus if you can
quantify by looking through a telescope
the complexity of something far away
then perhaps you can say well it was
produced by life is that correct
yeah yeah i can tell you something quick
and blow your mind don't have to use a
mass spec and use infrared so i came up
with a the brianal like this a
non-gravitationally lensing complexity
cloak what the [ __ ] is that well sorry
for swearing um so you know black holes
are black holes but if you could make an
object that would basically so in the
infrared um
infrared
radiation gets absorbed at specific
lines well all radiation gets specific
lines
but i came up with a way of making
molecules to store binary code of them
because i want to leave a message for
some aliens when the humanity is about
to end and put it in the atmosphere and
what you could do is you have these like
if you were able to say right i've got
all this spectrum and i want to cover
all of it i'm going to design a molecule
absorbs here here here here here
and i'll make it super light
there might be objects in the universe
that are non-gravitational lens in
complexity cloaks because they're light
and they can absorb all that energy
across and just re-radiate it some other
way or be used so it's like a it's kind
of like a dyson sphere but it's cooler
because it's it's basically really dark
over everything
and and what am i saying the reason i
was saying this to you kurt not only was
your explanation spot on you're talking
about mass spec but you could also
use infrared
um
spectroscopy and a telescope to go and
look for not just life but technology
that basically is showing itself in the
in the infrared and uv and maybe x-ray
whatever
okay great now on to the ufo question
brian when do you say that scientists
have an incentive to find life in the
universe and incentives via nobel prize
in money etc i don't buy that per se i
think they have an incentive to find a
certain form of life in the universe but
not life in general and the reason is
that life in general borders on what is
considered to be woo or paranormal for
example if you were to study ufos and
say is there credibility to these these
reports that's almost not done besides a
few individuals like kevin knuth for
example
because i
i i think almost none of us i don't
think any of us are actually pursuing
the truth including myself which is why
i don't like when people say this
channel is for truth seekers almost none
of us care about the truth per se
because the truth can be extremely hard
so we care about it in a certain bounded
fashion so we also care about our
reputations we care about not sounding
like these d in sensate to cerebrate
rednecks which is what the people in the
academy generally think of those who who
consider the ufo reports to be real they
they generally consider them to and
let's be honest they consider them to be
kooks and i think that academics
generally care much more about either
sounding intelligence or not appearing
to be inane
more than they care about the truth per
se
and so it's it's extremely bounded by
their
by their place in a social hierarchy by
their place among their peers they don't
want to be ostracized it's an
to analyze ufo reports so that's why i
say i don't buy
when
you say that well we have an extreme
incentive to find life in the universe a
certain type of life i agree
yeah well i think uh i think largely
that is accurate although i will say in
my defense you know i did join the
galileo project with our mutual friend
navi loeb uh specifically for this
reason not as a researcher but as a
member of the external oversight board
because i actually don't think they need
my help as an observational astronomer
i'm pretty good but you know harvard is
not exactly hurting for for money and
you know they can certainly raise
funding especially when you have the you
know former uh chairman the
longest-serving chairman in harvard's
history in the astronomy department at
the at the helm who's you know joe
rogan's appearance blew up the internet
and uh has has uh you know number five
bestseller um you know last year in the
new york times so i don't think they
need my help you know kind of
necessarily doing the research but i do
think they can always use help
holding them to account
and you know if i i told this to avi you
know i wouldn't have called it the
galileo project i think it's dangerous
when you know astronomers begin
by you know kind of bringing up the
names like bruno and and galileo and and
persecuted
figures in history i think that's a
fraught perilous endeavor and i think i
would be even that is sort of a be lying
a bias in other words his his claim is
that just like galileo uh suffered from
and the inability of the powers that be
the funding agencies of this time the
venetian dogens and senate and and other
agencies to at first look through in the
catholic church later on to look through
his telescope and and see for themselves
as if that would have proven anything i
mean just looking through a telescope
proves nothing it's the connection of
the human mind and the formulation of a
hypothesis and evidentiary data that
could disconfirm his hypothesis you know
galileo had many blunders kurt uh i'm
pleased and privileged to be working
with uh with uh jim gates carlo revelli
frank wilczyk fabiola giannatti and my
good friend from uh from uh graduate
school lucio picarillo on the first ever
audiobook version of any of galileo's
book and it's oh that's interesting and
i also didn't know that that was the
genesis of the word galileo in the
project i thought it just meant i'm
going to be looking out like galileo
looked down
no no i mean i i think the project's
really dangerous i'd like to kind of
push back on you i mean not push back
i'd like to reassure you i mean i can't
speak for brian just a second just a
second lee i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i
just want brian to finish because i i
interrupted him and then so please
finish brian and then and then leave
kurt's used to me and throw a punch
but so we're translating galileo's book
we have the rights to the first ever
audiobook for galileo uh with a forward
by einstein and uh that's read by frank
wilcheck winner of the nobel prize in
2004 and jim gates it's so what does it
say it says galileo was wrote the the
the definitive treatise on the
scientific method on what you're
supposed to do with evidence etc etc and
yet in that very book he makes a
catastrophic confirmation blunder at the
very end on day four it's a trialog
between these three characters i'm one
of them carlo revelli's another one and
my friend lucio's the other and we go
about and we're trying to disprove uh uh
galileo's character salviati is trying
to disprove uh the uh the the
earth-centered notion of the universe
that's held by simplicio the simpleton
uh who's espousing the words of the pope
uh that the earth is the center of the
universe and then i'm playing segreto
the kind of knowledgeable lay person who
is interpreting between them and gal is
a phenomenal writer but he goes through
and describes these things in such
loving detail that even i become
convinced when he goes about and says
that the tides on the earth are proof
that the earth is going around the sun
that's complete balderdash we know
that's not correct and it would take
newton to do it and his argument is very
simple and persuasive it uses data it
would have gotten accepted by nature
probably if nature had existed not like
you know lee's travails um but his
argument is that you've got this you
know you've got this object that's going
around the sun here's the sun over here
and here we've got tides on the earth
and uh as it goes around the sun it
orbits and the tide sloshes around and
that's why we have ti it's totally wrong
the tides are caused by the lunar
gravitational force the tidal force
quadripolar moment of the lunar
gravitational force field nothing to do
with our motion around the sun really
and yet it's incredibly persuasive and
so if you took the lessons of absolute
objective history and you say like
should we have listened to galileo no
you'd throw out that book you throw it
out he says nonsense even though he
brings up relativity for the first time
in human history the notion of relative
motion does not affect the laws of
nature which we now call a rents and
variants these are foundational things
and yet the summary of the book is
totally wrong the conclusion of the book
is totally misproven and he didn't use
the best evidence in hand so look for
that coming soon hopefully on galileo's
birthday in february but
this is all to say when it comes to when
it comes to avi's project avi loves
project um i think they need oversight
more than they need my insight which is
to say that i think the the first
reaction that we have to have is
skepticism because we do want to believe
i think if we all go back to our 12 year
old boys when we were 12 year old boys
forget about funding and and i'm gonna
lose my my my status as a chair
professor or lee's gonna lose no we're
just little boys and we're playing with
that little pebble on the beach like
ninten said and we're looking for a
shinier pebble if we were to discover
that i mean it raises the hair in the
back of my neck that there was
extraterrestrial intelligence first life
you know i i have my misgivings i've
talked to lee about that we'll talk
about that some other just about slime
mold on the planet enceladus or the moon
enceladus i don't think that will make
as big an impact as lee does but let's
leave that aside let's just talk about
ufos i
don't want to believe i want to have
evidence and i think if you if you bury
your head in the sand you won't get
evidence so i have to say
and i hope this is true of avi too uh
that we are kind of the boy the 12 year
old boys sitting on the on the bed not
being able to fall asleep at night
looking up at the stars we do want to
know the truth uh but we want to have
evidence for it as mature men as
scientists at this very moment so anyway
lee you were going to say you've got
some problems with with uh with the
project and i'm happy again i don't
speak for them i'm on their external
advisory committee i think it's
important to do but i am predisposed
it's like the bets that stephen hawking
used to make with kip thorne he would
bet against hawking radiation ever being
you know validated and uh so that if he
lost the bet you know he'd have the
thrill of intellectual superiority being
correct
uh so what say you lee
yeah i mean it's no big it's no big deal
i'm i think i'm i've got a lot of
sympathy for kurt's position
or kind of
um worry about where we are as
scientists look for ufos but i think
that i know avi very well he's great but
he's playing a very strange game here i
would like to say he's kind of saying oh
the scientific establishment's not ready
for this i'm a genuine conterian and i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna basically come
up with these things i'm being ignored
no he's just making stuff up
right making stuff up what is he making
up a theologian with leon cronin and
avilo is about to be booked we got a
plan
yeah so what i mean by he's making stuff
up he's making up a
false argument about um
that people are kind of you know when it
comes to this interstellar object that
came through and he was just he was
saying why it could be alien space junk
sure it could be all sorts of things but
but we were trying to understand
what the characteristics of trajectory
were telling us so he's kind of making
up stories which are fine i don't mean
he's fabricating stuff i mean he's
saying a narrative
and i'm wondering why is he making that
narrative what does he have to gain
other than some kind of you know fame
and notoriety and i'm going to be
downtrodden by the establishment because
if i suddenly said to brian hey brian
we've just found wormholes i saw it over
there look wormhole over there wormhole
over there wormhole over there and and
then brian says lee you haven't got any
wormholes you just may you know you
haven't got any date and i'll be like
you're just beating me up big professor
you know and i think it's a bit like
this so what i i'm really glad that
brian that is kind of borderline ad
hominem lee i have to point that out i
mean i love avi i fight with avi but but
that seems like imputing his impugning
his character almost you can
disassociate yourself from it what i'm
trying to say to so it's not clipped out
of context is that i like the idea of
searching
but i there is this so what i'm trying
to say there's this cultural vibe going
on right now our culture is changing
people are asking questions what are
these things that the pentagon has
released what is the probability of us
this happening
and and i'm saying that we don't
we could play together i would love to
help avi be successful i it doesn't i
don't think it's a
we i don't think the establishment is
against him i don't think even i'm in
the establishment we genuinely want to
know and i do agree with you that there
is some
we are putting we could put our careers
on the line if we get it wrong but
actually in science you have become
better scientists the more you're wrong
and what i'm saying here is abby's
adopting an extreme viewpoint where he
may not allow himself to be wrong and
it's not an ad hon i'm not saying he's
anything bad i'm not saying he's doing
anything dishonest i'm saying he's
making a narrative well let's be precise
so i had him on my show
and it was a wonderful episode and this
is long before i decided to join
and i said avi i don't believe that you
believe this is real that this
is an extraterrestrial and he says
and and i said because if you did you
happen to have access to a a resource
that's highly complex has a lot of uh
has a lot of assembly behind it called
yuri milner who is a russian billionaire
and he's showered upon uh you the
potential as a leader of the
breakthrough starshot uh prize one of
the leaders uh there's tremendous
resource so instead of sending you know
10 to the fourth uh cell phone cameras
to proxima century b
why don't you send one of them at you
know not even half the speed of light
not even 10 of the speedo just you know
three four percent and catch up to omumu
and you know what he said he said no no
we don't need to do that because when
reuben telescope which is the vera rubin
observatory in chile which is going to
be a phenomenal instrument it's designed
it was the original name was the
large-scale synoptic
survey telescope to survey the whole sky
with a huge cadence very quickly looking
for objects that are anomalous that
could do and he says that's one of the
dream machines for discovering we
already discovered one of them using pan
stars on hawaii um so we're going to
discover millions of these things i said
well avi you know i don't know if you
know about this but you know like uh you
know sometimes you know
things happen only once you know there's
an n of one problem that we talk about
and what if this yeah what if they are
abundant and what if there are forces
that conspire against in our solar
system just particularly not to the
cosmos to our solar system maybe the
lunar you know so tidal solar whatever
whatever it is um and it makes these
objects very very unlikely to ever be
seen again even though they're abundant
wouldn't you want to catch up to the
only one with all the resources you have
and he was sort of agnostic about it
that gave me some pause and that's one
of the things i'm going to push back on
as an external advisor but i i would you
know and i love you lee but but i don't
think he's doing it for fam i mean he
has an ego that's well known um he's he
has trouble controlling um you know
sometimes his passions for what he does
i think he's doing an incredible
valuable service but i just want to talk
about from the perspective as an
observational astronomer can
observational astronomers provide
information in the way that you've been
using it
about this phenomenon uh in other words
we survey the sky in all wavelength
bands 24 7 around the earth from
antarctica where i've been twice for two
months of my life uh and uh to the north
pole to space now we've got jwst um what
would it convince a believer
to
give up the uh the expectations in other
words carl sagan said lack of evidence
is not evidence of absence or absence of
evidence so we can't but we can't we
also have to admit we have conserved
resources and finite time which is the
most prominent of all reasons so let me
just come in quickly so i completely
agree we're all characters right and i
know avid is great
all i'm trying to say is um we i want
him to help i want him to succeed so
exactly i think my the only thing i
would comment here say how can we help
you let's help let's help you do this
right whatever you think the narratives
are it's capturing the day i do think we
have a responsibility though and it's
not an ad holmen it is kind of a bit way
in this polarization in the time of
covid elections we do have a
responsibility for correctly framing the
arguments we're not leading people down
the guard up the garden path that's the
only point i'm getting at mean being too
optimistic or being too high salesman
yeah exactly exactly that's all i mean
nothing else everything else is good so
what i would say to avi is like how can
we help you what i would say to kurt
it's like
what do you think
science science mainstream science is
doing enough of you're finding
frustrating because you know i'm i'm a
i'm a cheap scientist in the regard
i want to know why i'm in the universe i
want to know why i'm here i want to have
meaning
if there are aliens out there i want to
know it's not just the right type of
alien any will do me
any evidence um and and i
think about that
getting meaning from science and meaning
from life in the universe that might
have to be a part two uh kirk but but
anyway yeah i know we both
want we want evidence right we don't
want to just you know just marginally
and we only have finite amount of time
and intellectual time but don't forget
you know
our forgetting curve you know is peaking
i can tell you from experience in a few
years you're going to have trouble
remembering your kids names and you know
hopefully you know uh that'll stop but
uh but but we only have so much time for
attention to pay attention to things of
of of great import to us so i i you know
i guess the the subject is what what
else should we be doing we being
astronomers avi's not going to build you
know a large hadron collider squared you
know look for uh interdimensional aliens
you know manipulating wormholes to get
here right he's an astronomer he's a
theorist by the way he's not an observer
so so i think he needs help uh i think
the the you know having you involved you
know from that perspective but then how
do we translate the signatures from
assembly from you know can be how do we
translate that into an actionable metric
that will allow us to reduce our
uncertainty getting back to our rubric
at the beginning of this conversation
well let me answer
one direct thing i think we can do this
with image data and time series data and
one of the things that would be very
interesting is like if you take any
given image on its dimensionality and
let's say i mean kurt you've got
assembly in one second it's brilliant
right you can apply the same thing to
two-dimensional images and also time
series images of course you have to
define your axioms precisely like when
you're looking at how this image image
can be created it's very rare you see
like a straight edge in nature it just
doesn't happen right so you're looking
for yeah i mean and so i i think that's
right and i i what i would say um
quickly is
i've looked at these pentagon images and
i spoke to someone who was responsible
for releasing some of them and i was
like are you just trying to basically
are you just were you bored one day or
did you need more funding or something
why did you do it they were like no
actually we genuinely think
public paid for this data in a way and
we're just throwing it out there so what
i when i tried to get out of them what
they thought they wouldn't tell me so
what do you think of these images i mean
you must have i've looked at them i've
listened to people on podcasts on joe
rogan's podcast in particular and looked
at the data and there's all this
mischaracterization of different people
looking at different data sets and
saying things like there's this object
that i think brian you've talked about
this this this this uh this tic tac that
went from supposedly you know um very
high up to 50 feet off the ocean in like
a second um
but kurt you have a look at this data
what do you think of it do you think
it's compelling or or are you frustrated
about the quality or
what is your opinion i think it's sad
that people
hold these as as evidence of ufos
because i don't think they are
necessarily i think that they're
extremely poor evidence and what about
sightings what about what about
eyewitnesses
that's why all of it has to be looked at
so when someone if someone is to tell me
that bigfoot exists and i ask for
footage and then they show me some
pixelated video i don't think that
that's great evidence for bigfoot now
that in tandem with a variety of stories
from people who we would think of as
credible in any other situation that in
tandem with let's say a rape trial we
would send someone to jail based on two
or three witness testimonies and yet we
have a team of people who are extremely
credible who testify to the strangeness
of this phenomenon and then we don't we
think well perhaps their eyes are
misleading them well i don't think
that's reasonable so i think it's
strange i don't find any single one of
the videos to be compelling i find the
set of videos to be somewhat compelling
that there's something strange happening
but i find the total set of
i i'm putting evidence in scarecrow tier
of evidence of ufos to be
interesting and i also don't believe
that we want to believe in ufos i know
that you said that brian i know
well
i want to believe in i want to have
evidence yeah yeah well you also
mentioned that we have this need to
believe in external life and i don't
think that's true for me personally i
hope that all of what's happening with
ufos is false well lee said something
sorry kurt well i'm just afraid of the
implications and i think that anyone who
seriously thinks about this perhaps
should be because it may indicate that
we're not at the top of the food chain
it may mean that we don't mean what we
think we mean in terms of our place in
the universe our purpose even i feel the
same way about the prospects of hell i
don't want to believe in hell not that i
do but i don't want to believe in it in
some ways i don't want to believe in god
in some ways i find comfort in that
consciousness ends so there's so many
beliefs that people say well people have
a need to believe in in god people have
a need to believe in ufos some do some
don't and i think that if you seriously
thought about ufos perhaps
perhaps you would want to believe that
they don't exist when i say ufos i mean
obviously ufos exist the alien life
that's supposedly behind it is what i'm
referring to
all right well i think that exemplifies
why you're
one of the best in the business kurt and
what you do on this on this channel uh
and that you
have uh this you know kind of uh
humility epis epistemological humility
uh but you also have a tenacity and that
is a rare combination um i i think you
know one one nice place maybe to wrap up
and then
you know lee is often
i claim in a good sense you know my
belief fundamentally is that no one's an
atheist
everyone has a religion you know for
some even that don't go to you know
church or synagogue you know that
religion as i documented my first book
losing the nobel prize it is often the
nobel prize and this is kind of a kosher
idol you know that yeah it doesn't cause
that much harm and yeah funding
decisions are made about it and you know
lee's mentioned it more times than i
have today and it's obviously you know
top of mind for many scientists and and
zygasen hopefully he would win it i
don't have anything against the people
that win it i've interviewed a dozen of
them on my show but on the other hand um
you know there even lack of a religion
secularism um i think that there is a
religion of scientism which is that uh
science can provide meaning and i i'd
like to push back on that i'd like to
explore what lee and you think kurt
about this very notion in other words uh
the word science in in in
in in greek uh means knowledge it
doesn't mean wisdom you know sapien
means wisdom you know one who knows that
he knows sapianism i talked about this
lex friedman on the podcast that just
came out and look forward by the way to
lee cronin who inspired me you know to
to you know get connected to lex again
uh you know lex uh hosted lee before me
and uh lee helped me prepare a lot for
my episode because he was on lex's show
and he'll hopefully have that episode
out soon too might have been allegedly
i can't wait to see that one but you
know i talked about this you know that
that i don't get any meaning from
science i think scientific science is
intrinsically inherently you know we may
have curiosity and the motto of my
channel is abc always be curious uh but
curiosity and wisdom don't necessarily
go together and i documented many times
you know nobel laureates that were nazis
you know and had great knowledge and
used their knowledge of of of chemicals
and you know forefathers you know fritz
haber you know leak
way more engineered but yeah yeah yeah
it's evil you know and he was a jew in
his and his and his uh his icon b
eventually led to the gassing of many of
his own family members so anyway don't
look to science for wisdom so if you
can't look into it for wisdom
why do we look to it for meaning
so lee
i can i can give you a quick answer but
maybe it's your show where do you want
to go first yeah here's what i suggest i
suggest that we take a bathroom break
and then brian you check with your wife
see if it's okay if you keep talking for
a little while longer and leave with
whoever you have to speak to as well
because there are some audiences he has
to talk to the queen there are some
audience questions we haven't gotten to
oh yeah and i'd like to get to those
all right yeah yeah i've got i've got a
25 minute this just in my wife says 25
more months
i'll take a two-minute break yeah yeah
and also quickly before we go so yeah
lee do you have anything to promote i'll
make this transition smooth once we edit
this
do you oh
like a podcast channel or something
no i'm i'm i i'm pr i promote
what am i promoting i'm i think that um
i just want people to kind of ask more
questions and unfriend in in an unframed
way and and know that they can get
framed you know
i
i have
for me we'll talk about when we come
back from break but i genuinely love
not knowing and then finding a little
dent and then getting something yeah
it's like climbing a hill okay yeah
the answer is no he doesn't have
anything but you should
yeah because i wanted to just promote
right now and then let's go to the
washroom so people can click on this so
brian has losing the nobel prize as a
book you also have into the impossible
which is a book as well as a podcast and
the links are in the description i have
purchased both of them
additionally brian your interview with
lex friedman just came out either today
or yesterday so that's fresh and lee you
have a ted talk
and
i believe i believe an upcoming lex
freeman podcast interview hopefully
allegedly i'm not saying anything brian
spielberg's not me on lex's podcast we
have lex has an image of me and lee
talking on my podcast so it's definitely
coming out people who are watching just
click on those links and look up lee and
brian's
work see you soon
yeah back in a minute
you should know that
releasing in just a couple hours is the
stephon alexander interview and that one
we talk about matrix models and string
theory it's super interesting look
forward to that it's premiering in about
three hours
stefan alexander coincidentally or
perhaps not coincidentally is one of
brian keating's best friends if not his
best friend so are you at home are you
at the office
this is my home office oh i'm actually
i'm actually in fact in there in the
corner there that is the cellular
automata running in 3d in my led cube
that's interesting in fact it's conway's
game of life
um
you've incorrectly implemented boundary
conditions because i'm rubbish at that
interesting okay
my lab is moving the next way we're in
glasgow i'm in the old in the chemistry
department which is a lovely old
building
but it's not quite fit for purpose and
i'm moving my team onto a new floor
and we've got um
all these fume hoods all kitted out for
all the digital camera streak
so the dream experiment that i wanted to
build
10 years ago
will be constructed
in march
and we have the assembly meter
so you never know
by april 2024 we might have the answer
or an answer but
uh yeah so but i've been doing a lot of
work at home obviously with covid
we've all been trapped but now kobe is
almost hopefully cross whatever unless
unless the person who wrote it i'm
joking
has updated the firmware
i saw that on so it's like there's lots
of jokes at the moment about that
you know the problem with you know i was
listening some of your jokes brian but
was it someone about the problem of
omicron if we don't solve it now
you know what comes after omicron
he's pie and that just goes on forever
ah that's hilarious
who said that
oh it was on a it was on a podcast i
heard a uk political podcast um
uh called the bunker
so all the load of left wingers we what
we're sad about brexit oh i mean i'm sad
about brexit but i have no politics here
okay so let's get to some audience
questions
also well another time we can talk about
free will in time
we started off with that
we can solve we can solve time
consciousness and free will in one easy
podcast
[Laughter]
okay well briefly quickly
lee when you said that time is
fundamental i don't know if you actually
said that but when you you were talking
about entropic time is what we normally
think of as physicists as
as precipitating the arrow of time and
you're saying that well that may be the
wrong way of going about it so are your
views more aligned with lee because lee
believes time to be fundamental
but briefly lee if you don't mind i'm
sorry he hasn't lee smalling yeah yeah
sorry yeah yeah well so i first met lee
smolin and i told him my theory thomas
oh that's my theory and i'm like wow our
names are both lee
yeah so i mine is slightly more dramatic
and remember i'm a professional idiot
regis idiot and what i mean by that is
that um i don't get confined by
discipline boundaries so it was when i
first told sarah my theory of time she
was just like this just can't be true
you know this is just but all i'm saying
is that there is no such thing as space
there is time okay
and from and time creates space right in
some mechanism that we don't really
understand and um that breaks in
everything we need i tried to argue with
sean carroll about this but he didn't
even argue he said no you're just wrong
i was like why i said well my theory is
better time can go forward and backwards
and i'm like that breaks causality so
time is primal time creates space
and
um and there the
there is a finite amount of time that
has existed in our current universe
right that doesn't mean there aren't
things outside our universe and uh and
it works a bit like that and that's why
assembly
helps us quantify that through assembly
is almost like looks at the degree of
asymmetry since the beginning of time
that's recorded but i can i can budge on
some of it but that's it in two or three
sentences yeah we'll talk about that
we'll perhaps have another podcast and
so people who are watching if you have
questions for brian and or lee leave
them below okay brian do you have any
quick comments on the nature of time
before we get to the questions from the
audience
well i think you know time again is one
of these things that you know we kind of
know it when we see it it's it's like
you know what does it
feel like to be a bat you know nagel's
question you know so he's just like we
don't know
and i find that uh
sort of interpretable in the sense of we
know it when we feel it we know it when
we see it we have biological clocks
we're turning grayer and grey kurt
doesn't know that yet uh but but someday
he will uh we take comfort that his uh
diminution and beauty will only only
catch up to ourselves well you look like
buzz lightyear man that's a huge
compliment someone in the lex comments
said that and i thought man that's
exactly right and you're an astronomer
as well and lee you're a great looking
guy yeah i remember when i saw you i'm
like this is a good looking guy
i don't want to be in the same podcast
you're a good-looking guy too brian yeah
thank you very much but that means he
lives in a bubble you know you're power
you're a powerful looking guy brian i'd
say that
thank you thank you i do have a strong
aroma well well i'd rather be
okay never mind
so
time you know i had talked about this
with frank wilczyk on on my into the
impossible podcast i said what is time
you know just like i asked lee what is
life um yeah i asked uh other people
helping out philip goff on i'll ask him
what is consciousness you know it's like
we know it when we see it frank said to
me will chuck said you know time is what
clock's mentioned all right thanks a lot
you know yeah but anything could be a
clock so i think what's interesting is
to pursue the path that lee has pursued
uh you know what is the simplest mole
you know chemical that can form
with with inspiration with direction
towards evolutionary purposes and he has
simulations that you can see in his ted
talk about it's brilliant um i think
there's a experiment done at nist and
i'm going to have a nicole halpern
younger on who's a brilliant scientist
at nist in maryland and she has a new
book called quantum steampunk
which is really delightful kind of in
the vein of a roger penrose emperor's
new uh new mind uh in which she talks
about you know what is the world's
simplest clock and on my channel i make
explainer videos and one i did is what
is time and and how can you understand
time
um by making the world's simplest clock
and what is a clock something that ticks
okay well what is something that takes
well it has quantum states and i think
the revolution that would be interesting
for another podcast maybe lee and and
kurt will come on my podcast maybe with
avi loeb we can have a knockdown drag
out a conversation lee smallin just get
everybody in there mosh pit uh is to
talk about well what are the quantum
implications you know there's quantum
thermodynamics that's coming to the
front things like sillard entropy and
stuff that lee knows about that i'm just
learning about i think these are all
really fruitful and i wonder how that
could feed into things that lee is
working on but yeah for now maybe um you
want to talk about uh meaning from
science or do you want to talk audience
questions i want to do i want to make
sure that we answer all the audience
yeah let's get to the audience so this
one comes from
sneaky toaster
questions my kids that was the my first
choice for my middle child's middle name
so the question is eric weinstein and
others are advocating for the
irrefutable data the government has on
uap's ufos to be released to the science
community should the science community
be granted access
well i've pushed back with uh respect to
eric i've told them on clubhouse chats
on my you know what what do you mean
like the data like data is the data the
hubble deep field like if there are
aliens you know in the universe then you
know there's 10 to the fifth or ten to
the fourth galaxies in the hubble ultra
deep field then you know there's
probably an awful lot of aliens in there
you know go go for it but but but i
wonder you know is that really true
there's data again the hubble deep field
tells you exactly one thing as far as i
can tell maybe it tells you a little bit
more it allows you to estimate with
about 50 uncertainty and again the issue
is not the error it's not the value that
is measured the mantissa you know it is
the error bars that's where the science
comes in i can measure something even i
could go into lee's lab and make some
chemical reactions and you know i'd
probably make ho2 or you know whatever i
screw up everything i i joke that when i
did biology i would dissect the frog the
frog would live i'm terrible at these
wet sciences but the error bars that's
where the scientist comes out and i
think unless you tell me what is your
way of doing what's called a blind
analysis here's an example with my
telescopes i measure data i measure data
from the big bang the origin of the
universe the origin of the elements
called the cosmic microwave background
radiation if i make an observation of
the polarization looking for waves of
gravity that could indicate the presence
of an early exponential phase of
inflationary expansion which is you know
surely could garner many many accolades
and satiate our knowledge
of of perhaps all of the conjectures
about things called the multiverse well
if i do that
and i make a claim i have to show that
that data is immune from dust
but i also have to show that the data i
got on tuesday is the same as the data i
got on a wednesday and that the data i
got when the telescope was slewing to
the left at four degrees per second is
the same as the one and slew to the
right at four degrees for a second that
was a critical sorry
question
i want to frame something here because
this is almost getting what i was saying
about avi earlier and also um er what
eric is saying is that when he says show
us the data it's almost like there's
like he's kind of invoking some kind of
conspiracy and stuff and there's all
these you know little green men and what
brian's just really precisely is i know
what we want to know is at this spot on
earth at this time when this was
happening what was happening show a show
and show us so we've got a comparable
data control sorry to interrupt you
brian but i think it's really important
that we because we we're both eye to eye
on this yeah
the point is you have to tell me ahead
of time when i do an analysis we have to
show in a blind analysis what the error
bar will get for a variety of different
scenarios until you tell me i might give
you data but until you tell me and
actually we don't even do it because
it's a tremendous amount of work for us
to process data in a way that another
person could come in to understand
calibration flat fielding spectral
spectral line flat
dark currents all the things that go
into just imaging and imaging is simple
compared to measuring the cmb uh just in
terms of like these detectors have been
around 40 years longer than the type of
detectors that i'm working with um i'm
not saying it's easier or harder
globally or more important but the
bottom line is i have to my student has
to tell me how she's going to analyze
the data and how she's going to assess
the final error bar long before we
unblind and let her see the results so
tell me how could you mistakenly
interpret in the image which i don't
think is really as prohibitive as
spectral data or radar data whatever but
let's just stipulate it as tell me how
you're going to interpret to guard
against this feynman said you fooling
yourself and you everyone i'm looking at
you out there you are the easiest person
to fool i'm happy to share data and i'll
advocate for you
about getting data out of the galileo
project however you have to do some
legwork too you can't say oh they're
hiding it from me therefore they're
hiding something forever no
tell me what you're going to do with it
tell me how you're going to prove
yourself wrong and so that i will say to
you you are my fellow scientist even
though you may not have a phd
okay this was a live chat question
someone wants to know lee tom poliska
tom poleski asks lee why hasn't your
seti experiment with spectrograph in the
infrared been done by anyone yet
because i happen to have a big mouth and
like all this stuff happening in the lab
i always talk about fraud publish it but
the paper's almost finished and when
people said to me you couldn't possibly
get assembly number our mass spectator
and we did i think but we can do it with
a thing called nmr nuclear magnetic
resonance and infrared and we've just
done it and we proved it works so i very
much hope that once we get this out
there that we will put out enough um
data and uh and the algorithm required
for people to start an experiment indeed
there are people who are going to be
getting um spectroscopy uh expression
spectroscopic data from out the solar
system which want to try with try this
with but we need to be cautious because
the resolution is really so poor there's
limited amount of things we can do but
my dream would be to put a spectrometer
an infrared spectrometer in in orbit
above venus there's a lot of and maybe
one in orbit maybe in titan and we could
do exactly that experiment so it's a
really good point and literally assembly
theory was kind of invented last year
we published the paper the experiment in
the mass effect paper in may
we've been working on several theory
papers and more experimental paper and
that's just coming so yeah it's really
literally hot off the press so it's not
made up it works but i just need to
literally get it into a pre-print in
publication and i'm talking to various
organizations that may or may not have
lots of money and may or may not have
lots of maybe private and public that
are planning missions
and um and i'm advocating very strongly
for us to do that
send send a telescope they can do
infrared spectroscopy all around the
solar system and map the assembliness of
everything
okay this question comes from vissen
cosmin this is to both of you ask all of
your materialist guests to give one
single example of something outside of
consciousness
uh i think there are
great difficulties in doing that simply
because we are the ghost in the machine
that is defining a what consciousness is
what our experience is what is
materialistic or not i should say that
you know i'm much more
much less materialistic than i assume
lee is i know what he is i don't know so
much about kurt but i'd love to know
more uh in that there are um what i
usually talk about is
you know are there is there permission
to believe not not the proof i said this
on lex's pocket like i don't care if i
believe in god you know like
does god need me does god care about
brian keating who gives a cry you know
um you know maybe maybe if god believes
in me you know if god exists but the
question of whether or not you i'm a
behaviorist so i think that people
manifest how they behave uh the
underlying consciousness that they are
internalized have that they have
internalized is is manifest externally
by their behaviors so i look to things
like religion in a very practical sense
can this give can this give community
can this give a purpose can this without
necessarily accepting the reality
as provable in a scientific context i
don't think you can prove or disprove
and i give upgrade my religious friends
too i say if you don't learn science
you're you're basically just you know
kind of living in this bubble if you
don't learn because science may actually
bolster your faith
as i said you know lex's podcast i've
said other places you know what if the
fact that we can perceive an infinite
spectrum of colors an infinite diversity
of life an infinite number of tastes and
you know dimensionality of what could be
otherwise
and the fact that the universe is
extravagant
is potentially uh a clue a symbol a
talisman i'm not saying it's proof of
course because i don't think there can
be proof
but um but i think those are sort of a
non-materialistic but again it's
materialistic and a reductionist sense
because i do believe that you can
practice it for your own benefit you can
you can glean wisdom from it you can
glean experienced community charity
things that improve you stoicism you
know i'm one of the few people i read
the christian bible every day in the
jewish bible every day i read the stoics
the ancient greeks the romans
these are things that i think broaden
your mind whether you believe it has to
be true or not so i'm more of a
pragmatist i would say in terms of what
consciousness things could not be
explainable via science
i'm going to ask you one more time
simply so can you point to something
that exists outside consciousness
there's lots of things that exist
outside consciousness but i think we
have to do that doing that null
experiment is hard right
i think that the causal chain that gave
gave rise so how chemistry so i'm going
to give the boring answer but i think
that um the
the
the process of
evolution in the universe and selection
exists outside consciousness because it
had to invent consciousness i would be
interested to know if computation is a
fundamental thing in the universe that
didn't need to go through consciousness
um that's an interesting question but my
my simple answer is i think that a lot
of you the universe exists outside of
consciousness but i will never
really
convincingly be able to prove it because
i am a conscious entity
just to make it clear because i want to
make sure this person doesn't write in
the comments say they equivocated what
is one example of something that is
outside consciousness
i think understanding consciousness i
think the meta problem of
you know what is it like to be a bad how
do you how do you separate in the heart
you know david charles is coming on my
show in a couple weeks i'll certainly
ask him this question oh you're saying
yeah you're saying something beyond
conscious comprehension intrinsically
right is that why
i think here's what the person is
getting at let's imagine i say x is
outside consciousness well that x
appears to you in your own consciousness
so it's not technically outside
consciousness now you can think maybe it
can exist besides me outside of me but
even that itself is an idea within
consciousness the easy answer right and
i think brian well i mean i think brian
might agree with this is like i'm not
i think that
um the ground truth for quantum
mechanics appears to be outside of
consciousness because quantum mechanics
wasn't constructed of conscious beings
and then we get all us and it's shown by
you know there are people who are
closets many worlds people right
and they get really stuck another thing
is that before that
i can
imagine
that there might be something outside of
the universe that is entirely separate
to this universe i can imagine it
but i just but i there is something
beyond my imagination because clearly
what can it be right i mean i could say
this is really like me saying i can
imagine all the set of prime numbers but
i can't tell you what the next one is
and that's really important so i think
there are things outside of that are
intrinsically outside of consciousness
and
and um and i think that we have to be
humble because i think even if we think
we could nail everything
i mean actually i'm i'm not religious
right but i have a great deal of respect
for uh religious people i do not like
the approach that richard dawkins and
lawrence krauss take to people who have
religion and say they're stupid because
they're not they have belief
and i have beliefs and my beliefs are
kind of a bit boring but i do have
beliefs and one of the reasons why i get
a buzz out of science is um i'm taking
something in my belief box and putting
it into my
fact box and it's not that i'm trying to
disprove god but it's like i'm going
through this process of actually
understanding more about the universe
the more in awe of it and the more i
know there's more belief and so i don't
think ever again that's the answer so i
think of course intrinsically there must
be things i think is this provable i
think we would need to get a proper
philosopher who would take us through
the thought processes and understanding
how it set up the axioms and the
argument but i believe my crude answer
would be probably almost yes there's
lots outside of our consciousness
okay this question comes from david and
it's directed towards you lee but you
can comment on it as well
brian in what sense does lee think that
we need new laws for life like extra
stuff at the fundamental level or some
emergent higher level type of stuff
well um i've already said it i think
that so not new laws necessarily but i
think that i well i would say that we we
can get rid of some laws get rid of the
second law and account for it correctly
so i think there's a new law needed
there so we have to remove the second
law we have to deal with the fact that
we require order at the beginning again
get rid of the second law have time so i
i don't think there's a the nice thing
about this is it's provable it's gonna
be experimentally tractable so i'm not
saying we need to tear up all the rules
i'm just saying that newtonian mechanics
um
is um not appropriate
and and i think i would say something
very
very crisp here and i i'm so this very
i think lee smolin has the same idea
that everything in the universe every
object and every event is unique because
it has a unique place in the universe
as i said to the person we talked about
earlier when i went to austin i flew to
austin i've been austin before and i
flew back to london
i've been to those places before but
i've no i've never been there before
because the planet in a different place
in our solar system and our solar system
is a different part in space
and so i think that we need to
understand
that time is not reversible and that
physicists should stop be given a free
get out a jail card we're allowing time
travel because i think that's cheating
causality so i would say answer that
question is that we need to be clear
about causation from
quarks
all the way up to you know from rocks to
rachmaninoff so i think yes we need a
new formulation of the laws but it's not
magic it's just reframing
brian
well i would say they're
um it's poetic it's the certain
romanticism about what lee's talking
about i think strictly speaking you know
i don't i always say you know
cosmology is the one specialization of
physics that doesn't require biology you
know it's like almost everything else
yeah uh to to instantiate itself um or
perhaps the other way around i didn't
never make use of when i teach my
undergraduate say you're gonna learn
thermodynamics electromagnetism nuclear
physics particle physics but you're not
going to learn anything about biophysics
or you know you'll even learn some
chemistry right we'll talk a little bit
about the formation of the chemical
elements
but that being said i don't think that
there's anything
to learn about g minus two of the muon
or of uh sterile neutrinos or you know
from a new interpretation that involves
life i think you know much much like i
joke about this like string theory is
the best theory ever made to describe
problems in string theory in other words
there'll be new technology there'll be
new
um you know uh new new kind of tools uh
that could be used new tactics to
approach the problem the essence of life
and don't forget erin schrodinger
recently cancelled by the way did you
hear about that the schrodinger's been
cancelled um uh finally uh for for some
uh sexual improprieties uh that are
quite awful if true
but the bottom line is no i don't think
that to understand um that there may be
additional forces and fields
gauge bosons and so forth at the in the
standard model there probably certainly
are i don't know um and uh but but i
don't think that those will necessitate
or require uh the conceptions of life to
be uh emergent within them
so i've pushed back to brian slightly i
want to push for i agree with what brian
said but i think he's kind of
causation physics doesn't have causation
at this in in the standard model in the
core models we call it and that is a big
error and i am really certain very
strongly with some courage and humility
that i think that we need to add that in
and i think brian correct me if i'm
wrong because we're kind of left the
ring now we're kind of like with we've i
don't know if it's a draw or there was a
who went on point but i would say that
really
um we do need causation at the beginning
um
then that is that that shouldn't be that
shouldn't be because when i speak to
frank we'll check about it he just
he just i mean i have speaking to him
about it and he was very
very good he's very smart he's a bit
cheeky you know he should do this and
some people get prizes for that and i
was like it's just a price dude who
cares
tell me if causation is at the beginning
right and i couldn't work on it you know
i mean there are people that talk about
the causal you know the structure joe
amageo lee smallin stefan alexander is
the going to be on soon on on this very
podcast so yeah no i i agree um i would
i would you know maybe maybe just just
kind of rectify my comment by saying i
don't
personally have much you know faith in
say the wolf rami and which is the most
kind of like life like you know at least
in terms of complexity
and rules and algorithmically uh
computable um essence that that will you
know make concrete astrophysical
predictions that laws will emerge from
it um and maybe it may be that you know
understanding life allows us to
understand artificial intelligence which
then allows us to make up new laws i'm
also kind of a ai minimalist but but
that's really a podcast for another time
because i would just think that the wife
and kids will come and get me soon curt
okay so then this is the last one and it
relates to what you said about causation
okay why is this this is from kamar 910
why is there something rather than
nothing and lee when you say causation
so physicists obviously study causal
structures like brian mentioned but
those usually mean you're within the
light cone and it's as simple as that
not this caused this so when you have a
model of causation which i'm unsure how
one can formulate that how does that not
lead to an infinite regress or either an
uncaused cause that at some point
especially if you consider time to be
fundamental
which ties into why is there something
rather than nothing which is kamar's
question
yeah let me give you two cent summaries
so the theory paper i'm just finishing
with sarah right now actually tackles
that very question
and and it's except that there are there
at the beginning there is no causation
and but that causation gets baked in
when when information can be stored
about the past that can affect something
differently in the future and it's
really as simple as that and the only
reason physicists have missed it is
because they call screen it out
so all i'm asked all i'm slightly asking
for is to remove entropy
change it to assembly have time going
forward and suddenly you do have causal
cones and those causal cones actually
are limited by the light cone and i
think that brian and i one day will be
talking about assembly cosmology and
we'll be looking for those artifacts out
there but i think we'll we're a little
bit far away from that i need to prove
the theory do the experiments get the
data show the error convince peers
because right now it's just a kind of
cool idea a bit like lots of things in
string theory and you get that
mathematical structure in reality
and i think we'll be able to but we'll
have to be held account on that so it's
a really good question um but i'm pretty
sure i know where it is
what we're doing right i'm also going to
re-ask you lee so you can expound some
more but brian has to go so brian please
uh so again the question from kumar
again is why is there something rather
than nothing okay so what i thought lee
might say is the why questions are kind
of anathema even though they're the most
interesting questions and the most
natural questions my my toddler will ask
me why why why and of course lee as a
parent kurt doesn't know this yet
because he's not a dad yet but please
god you'll be a father soon uh kurt you
and your lovely wife but lee knows the
ultimate causal chain with an infinite
series of why questions lee how do we
answer our kids
i guess so i mean i just say just tell
them to look for themselves or to shut
up asking the question right the answer
why why why why why why why why why
because i said so okay there is a way
this regression is
right
because i said so but look you have a
point you have an origin
and you have a cause and effect now the
infinite request isn't infinite what
happens is this is i just don't want to
this is the mechanism selection so what
this person does i'm sorry you have to
get you have to brian has to go and i'm
going to talk to you about so you can
keep talking about that but after brian
goes i i know what it's like to have a
wife that wants you to go on immediately
no no i mean mine too i think lee is is
is uh is correct and i and i do want to
see this and maybe i'll talk with sarah
about that when she comes on my show
but um but ultimately why questions are
not necessarily part of what scientists
should do why implies a meaning and i
think meaning you know it will bring up
questions of you know teleological
implications uh and i i don't mean that
they're necessarily anathema but usually
when people ask why they mean how or
what um you know how did how did the
causal chain get established uh those
have great answers in in in cosmology as
well except they have great problems too
and great mysteries and lee alluded to
three hours ago now almost which was you
know how did the whole thing get kicked
off and and what was the initial
generation of you know a universe and
and so forth you could ask why is there
a universe but i think that the question
of of of why first of all could be
trivial if it didn't exist we wouldn't
be here asking why it doesn't exist
and uh and and there's your whiskey
that's wonderful i wish i could have
some scottish some scottish coffee at
this time of the day um but uh but in
reality
in cosmology as kurt now you and i
talked you know i only i only have one
regret when it comes to kurds that i was
on his channel when it had the square
root of the number of viewers that it
does now and it deserves the square of
the number or if not more uh but uh but
we talked about briefly you know what
are the laws of physics are they
so-called geodesically complete can we
extrapolate the laws and chain of
causality within the light cone when you
have a singularity and lee mentioned
singularity a few times i happen to not
to believe that there is a quantum
theory of gravity at least i don't
believe is as well motivated i think
physicists get distracted by it i think
that they're pursuing the theory of
everything for the grandeur the glory
the the accolades that einstein never
lived up to that's the very first
paragraph of michio cocco's new book you
know einstein died with his unfinished
symphony that he couldn't come up with
the theory of everything no despite that
being the name of this channel i think
the gut is almost you know being
overlooked the grand unified theory we
don't understand how the lower energy
forces or the higher energy force are
unified let alone how all four are
unified and who if not you know uh one
of us has the temerity to say that there
has to be a law of quantum gravity what
if there's not so i'll channel my inner
uh you know lee and and say you know i
don't believe that there is quantum
gravity because i want to inspire my
colleagues to think harder about it and
we've been going about this for decades
now with little signs of progress
not to say to stop even string theory
which i have my problems with um but the
alternative as they say you know uh the
the string theory is the worst theory
except for all the others uh that could
be true according to whitten um but but
i think ultimately the why questions are
the most interesting but we should be
careful not to ask for motivation i
think that evokes teleology but um but
also we should be very precise we should
answer all the how questions as galileo
said
measure what is measurable and make
measurable what is not yet so
and as experimentalists lee and i try to
do that
yeah that's a great way to end it put it
i agree
thank you so much to the both of you i
appreciate it and the audience does as
well
my pleasure thank you kurt and thank you
lee i can't wait to be uh together with
both of you guys at some point in the
near future light cone
and all the links yeah and all of the
links to
lee cronin's and brian keating's work
are in the description
thank you
okay thanks guys good job
so lee i know i was cutting you off but
i know brian has to go did you want to
expand on what you were saying before
yeah just very quickly so this whole
idea for infinite regress doesn't have
to happen if you haven't if you have an
origin and you have some events to
happen like the the events are random
but as soon as they start to um
although they're random as they go on in
time they become contingent
because what happens in the future has
some relationship to that in the past
and as long as you don't call screen it
out now
when you start to then create an object
that can then that object can then
actually
interact on the infinite regress don't
go back in the loop but not back to the
beginning and give
some knowledge from the future if you
like to the past
then that infinite regress is not an
infinite regress it's just selection so
what that means is you have a series of
processes where you make an object so
let's just say you've got some
um some
uh chemistry occurring you've got let's
say you have two different streams of
chemistry
and they're random right but then in
each stream so you've got stream a
random stream b random and they're
becoming less random there's some
structure and then stream a
is able to interact with stream b
and to change the reaction
um so it can act back on itself with
more efficiency so that's something that
b can act back on itself yeah and then
you basically then then you get all
sorts of crazy things going because then
a and b become intertwined and mutually
dependent and then that goes up and then
this process of selection
starts to transition and i think that's
the secret but i haven't got there yet
um we have seen evidence of this in the
laboratory
and i think this is the answer to the
origin of life but we need to literally
run the experiment put a heavy emphasis
on selection and i'm wondering does
section selection in your model of life
come prior to reproducing and variations
sounds like variation was there though
in the a and the b yes so variation was
first that produced selection which then
produced actually
yeah when you have heterogeneity
and then you can get selection
uh and um this kind of variation and and
things
interacting and evolution can actually
still occur on very long time scales and
these in these on these on these
infinite timelines if you like and what
happens is that biology weaponizes
evolution through through autonomous
reproduction because it like grabs all
those calls or chains and can combine
them together in one object and the way
it weaponizes is it basically
replicates the genome stores information
very efficiently from the environment
and then adapts and it can
basically produce lots of attempts
at copying itself with slightly
different causal structures and so why
why i see biology is biology is like a
it creates evolution which is an
amplifier for selection and all the
universe is trying to do is
become fitter
i see i i'm having a difficult time
understanding it and i think it's
because i don't know what definition of
cause you're using to say that there was
a first cause that came from something
that was uncaused so i think that's
where my what i'm just saying you've
just got basically is let's think about
symmetry breaking so you've got a highly
symmetrical system and then things
interact
and time because the thing is this is
where physicists get really stuck in
that if you've got a time symmetric
system where does the symmetry breaking
come from you have to add something in
an imperfection
a a heterosome heterogeneity in
homogeneity
if you have time you break that symmetry
necessarily
so there's something really interesting
that we don't understand about time but
um but that's probably for another
podcast sure man and and the door's open
if you ever want to come back on and
talk about that yeah absolutely yeah
yeah it was really really we you were
very patient with us so it's good
because i think brian brian is a really
great debater and it's you know i've got
a lot of respect for him and what he's
doing and he's really he's his mission
is very good the way he's being precise
i'm learning a lot from him so it was a
pleasure honor indeed to kind of be with
both of you guys and talking yeah so the
honor is all mine man thank you so much
all right you have a nice day see you
take care man and any notes that you
have for me just email me and we can
absolutely we'll communicate there i'll
stay and talk to the audience for a
little bit sorry
impressed by the questions that also uh
that you really hadn't looked up the
assembly theory so i'll ask you about it
sometimes
all right man
take care bye
the theory of everyone with tyler
goldstein asks why does he think quantum
mechanics is outside of consciousness
that was my question as well
because you have to presume something
exists outside of consciousness in order
to prove that something exists outside
of it
thank you travis thank you
lj
thank you project malice
thank you sendip thank you corey
thank you phillip
thank you zanjari
one more time there's a podcast coming
out in about two
hours or so with stefan alexander that's
actually a fantastic podcast i was
holding off on publishing that for a
while because i didn't think it was
i think i thought it was incomplete and
i wanted to speak to with stefan some
more
and make it
into a fuller package however as i was
editing it today it seems like wow it's
a wonderful podcast so i expect it to do
well and it's a different podcast it's
an extremely technical podcast
generally when i talk to the physicists
it gets far more technical than
virtually any of the other podcasts and
there's a reason for that i think that's
i think there is a lacking
of that type of content someone wants to
know humphrey wants to know what was it
like spending four hours with chris
langan it was actually longer the
podcast was cut down
hey i like chris chris is a is chris is
he's obstreperous
seemingly but he's a teddy bear
at least to me
so i like chris i can understand why
people
consider him to be abrasive but that's
no but even if he is that's no
well many of the most intelligent people
can be
and it's
that's an ad hominem if one wants to
discount his ideas based on that okay
well
take care everyone thank you so much for
joining
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t
j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l that is kurt jaimungle
it's support from the patrons and from
the sponsors that allow me to do this
full-time every dollar helps
tremendously thank you